Hm,
hm hm.
Hm.
Should I put it in airplane mode?
Okay,
so God is dead.
He.
No,
we about a bunch of people that are a
birthday cake for God.
Whoa.
What the fuck do I do with this now?
And it's infinity candles.
Do you know how fucking bad ass
Nietzsche he felt when he said that for
the first time where he was like,
God is dead when it meant something like
now you say and people are like
whatever.
Who Cares?
Yeah,
no shit.
But like it was like a fucking.
It was like a nuclear bomb going off the
declaration.
God is dead.
Do you not understand these dad?
What did meet you wrote that?
I don't know man.
I don't.
Actually I,
you know,
I have no idea.
It was,
must've been the 19 hundreds or so.
I don't know when he was,
Nietzsche was around.
He's in my call young pile while I'm
always like,
one day I'm going to really get into his
work.
Oh man,
he's a,
he's good because he gets into your
fucking head man because he like Carl
young getting your habit.
It's more subtle.
Whereas like Nietzsche,
like you're reading,
you ever read a Philip k Dick?
Yes.
So you know how like you're getting on
top of 18,
82.
Wow.
What?
Philip k Dot Dick.
He was kind of crazy,
but he was genius.
So when you read his,
his fiction,
it's like you stop reading it and you
feel a little crazy for a second because
something about the way he's writing
just isn't normally something off man.
Nietzsche,
it's the same way.
It's like when you stop reading him,
you're going to like spend the next few
days like fuck.
Or like burroughs.
Yeah,
same,
same thing.
An outsider artists kind of like,
I remember reading some of burrows stuff
and thinking like I might get high just
reading this.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
like naked lunch.
That was him,
right?
That Terence Mckenna at the same thing.
Oh yeah.
You just start tripping when you start
reading his writing.
Like could you just start to think,
God,
I wish I could write like that man.
You could.
How dare you?
Well,
I mean you would have to spend a lot of
time.
Right?
And if it's all it is,
yeah,
that's the only thing that's holding you
back because the amount of time that you
would've spent writing,
you would love it.
You would enjoy it.
You know,
he saw Mckenna had some fascinating
books,
food of the Gods.
Oh,
here's some crazy fucking theories that
he pitched that I've seen scientists
like bow the especially the doubling of
the human brain size one.
That was a really fascinating theory
that he had,
that he.
He connected it.
I'm she,
I'm not sure if he was right in terms of
the climate of logical data,
but his contention for those,
were you aware of it?
It was a monkey's had come down from the
trees and they experimented with new
food sources and they started flipping
over cow patties to get the books
because that's what they do.
And along the line they discovered
silicide mushrooms and he thinks that
the grasslands,
the rain forest becoming grasslands,
the changing climate led to these
chimps,
these monkeys,
whatever our ancestors
were led to them becoming more
experimental.
And that,
that qbe coincided with a bunch of
different things that they know about
mushrooms or it could be a sort of
confirmed with a bunch of different
things.
One with that mushrooms increased visual
acuity and they shown this like in
actual actual test with real scientists
who were experimenting with it.
Who was the other guy?
There was one German guy,
a straight guy to that experimented with
this.
God Damn it.
Trying to remember his name,
but he was.
He had a really funny line.
What do you mean a straight gas straight
guy?
Meaning he wasn't a drug guy,
he wasn't a drug culture guy.
I don't mean straight like homosexual,
heterosexual.
I mean like uh,
he wasn't like Timothy leary or Mckenna
or you know,
any of these guys are like clear
proponents of psychedelics.
He was just,
I'm a researcher.
And they had found out that in low doses
of Psilocybin,
like say if you change an angle,
if you have two parallel lines and you
made one just varied it ever so slightly
with the Psilocybin,
they could tell when the angle was ever
so slightly varied quicker than they
could naturally.
Yeah.
I,
I can remember.
Yeah.
It's a visual acuity acuity and the in
the periphery.
So it's like expanding your peripheral
vision by a tiny,
tiny little bit.
Yeah.
I don't know if the test pertained to
periphery only.
It might've been peripherally as well
because I do remember that one specific
task,
that one specific thing where they were
trying to figure out,
um,
how quickly you could recognize one of
the angles changed and you could do it
quicker when you were high.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So there's that.
And then there's the horniness mushrooms
have known to make people horny.
So that happens.
We are known for that.
The creativity aspect of it,
there's that,
you know,
like the,
the tapping into alternative ways of
thinking and that would lead to a lot of
innovation.
And it's also possible that,
that it's really possible,
it's silicide been in some ways is a
nutrient mean.
It's also,
it's an intoxicant for sure.
It's an a hallucinogenic,
yes,
whatever that means,
but it,
it might be a nutrient to.
It's entirely possible that this
increase in visual acuity and this,
uh,
this horniness that it gives you in this
connection to nature and this,
uh,
intense creativity like you're tapping
into a river of ideas and like scooping
out buckets of them.
Yeah,
like all that might also.
It might be something that when you're
consuming,
it's actually beneficial to the body or
beneficial to your brain if it's having
all those crazy positive effects on the
brain,
they might have like a beneficial long
term effect on the brain.
And they've been doing these studies on
neurons on repairing neurons and
psilocybin and psilocybin bins role in
repairing brain disease,
brain brain issues.
Brain trauma might not have been
neurons.
So you could find that,
um,
the most recent studies with psilocybin
and brain damage and they think it might
in some ways be able to repair brain
damage.
Well,
if that's the case,
what if these monkeys were just eating
them all the time and their brains just
grew?
I mean,
what if Mckenna was right?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I think,
I think it is pretty safe.
A safe bet that a monkeys are what I
mean,
monkey isn't the right word.
Proto Hominids right?
Who are wandering the planes are gonna.
Like if we're omnivores,
we're definitely going to be eating
whatever,
uh,
whatever.
We can find that.
It gives us nutrition that has
nutritional value.
Especially if you're out in the hunt,
you're hungry.
The thing you're hunting,
shitting food is growing out of it.
Shit.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't even think they were hunting
then.
I don't think they could hunt something
that big.
I don't think they had weapons.
What do you mean?
Think what they were doing was they were
gathering,
they were eating a lot of bugs.
We were insectivore.
I thought his idea was that the,
there's climate change and so we start
moving into the grasslands and then
yeah,
we're hunting bovine animal.
So we're like.
So I don't think that was the
contention.
Contention was flipping over the cow
patties.
I thought it was that because the thing
that you're hunting is going to be
shitting things that grow mushrooms.
No,
I don't think so.
I think it was way later when they
started doing that.
Um,
one of the things.
Here's a study that Jamie pulled up.
It says psilocybin mushrooms stimulate
the growth of brain cells.
Psychedelic mushrooms have already had a
reputation for helping people open their
minds and broaden their perspectives in
the world.
Some have shown the ability to combat
mental disorders like depression,
anxiety,
and now research is showing that magic
mushrooms can actually help physically
rebuild a damaged brain.
Well,
if that's the case,
it was a case that it can physically
help rebuild a damaged brain,
maybe over longterm consumption.
It can actually make a brain grow.
I think I'm almost positive that
Mckenna's idea was not that they were
hunting these things,
but they were flipping over cow patties
looking for beetles and forums and
stuff.
Because I think we're talking about like
really small,
ancient hominids.
Okay.
We really hunted until we figured out
tools or I mean not like large scale
large animal type hunting.
So that was,
I think that was way later than the
human brain size growing.
Like when they,
when they develop like the adult adult
you ever seen someone use that?
Now it's the precursor to the bow and
Arrow before the bow and arrow,
they figured out a thing called an adult
adult.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It's a,
it's got a handle on it and you put a
spear in it and you launch the spear
with a handle like almost like it's a
crazy lacrosse ball that's there.
That's what it looks like.
There's guys that make,
um,
and there's videos.
Jamie,
you could see a guy that made his own
and used it.
There's a bunch of them actually.
But uh,
you know,
people take those things and they,
they throw them at targets and they're
not very accurate.
I mean they're okay.
Accurate in comparison to I guess if you
were,
you weren't skilled and you try to hit
it with a rock.
I mean it's probably more accurate than
that.
And if you could sneak up on an animal,
you could probably get some good
penetration and they probably got really
good at it eventually.
But that was the first of many weapons
that could launch things through the air
that they figured out.
Okay.
Have you seen that?
I'm that weird ritual that chimpanzees
are doing where they throw rocks at a
tree if you seen that?
Yeah.
What does that or they don't know.
It just is like,
it's the idea that like they're
developing their own weird culture,
their own superstition or something,
something that they just feel like
something,
they're doing something.
I mean we don't understand what it is,
but it's a thing where you throwing
rocks at trees and then there's all
these rocks that are kind of like laying
around certain trees because chimps have
decided to just start lobbing rocks at
him.
And they were saying,
is this like some emerging chimpanzee
religion or culture?
Like,
Oh yeah,
it's very weird man.
Like what?
What are they doing?
Why
do you know that they have.
It's sort of been agreed upon by a lot
of the people that study these animals
that they're entering to the Stone Age,
right?
Like this is,
this is the actual,
like when they're talking about
chimpanzees and they're looking at their
growth in their learning,
they're thinking they're in a new place,
they're thinking they're starting to use
tools and they're starting to use stones
and other great apes are using tools as
well.
Like we knew that they would get not we,
like you and I are out there doing
research
as we predicted it,
as we predicted Duncan,
they,
you know,
we always knew that you sticks to get
like termites and stuff,
but now they're figuring out a way to do
all kinds of crazy shit.
Have you ever seen the one orangutan
that figured out how to spearfish?
Yeah,
I did see that shit fucking picture of
him hanging over the river with a spirit
is easy.
It's insane.
To me.
What's really particularly interesting
is that as well as our society and our
species is moving into some new era as
we're moving into some.
God knows what the fuck it is.
These guys are too.
They're moving for them.
That what?
That state of the art.
That's some high.
That's fucking.
You're looking at God in my Elon Musk
right there.
That's the Elan Musk have a rank.
It's like,
what the fuck?
Look at him.
He's like,
fucking using that thing to get fish.
He's a genius.
That's genius.
Like in the same way that like we have
people sending things to Mars,
but it's funny that the two are
coinciding like.
It's funny that it appears now.
I don't know how long has it been going
on,
but it seems like this sort of trickle
in of stories of monkeys suddenly doing,
doing things like this.
It could be related to just more people
researching and getting more data that's
always been there.
Who knows?
One Jamie or the same chip.
The same orangutan is the same guy.
Oh,
there's a whole of them doing it.
Oh Shit.
Funny.
Orangutang fishing.
Wow.
Ha Ha.
It's just funny.
You're your leap forward in evolutionary
history.
It's funny to see huge hairy thing,
so we're looking at them sitting there
hanging on this rock looking over at
this little puddle that they have
fishing and it's obviously set up.
So I think they probably taught him how
to do this.
He's not fishing in the wild.
He's like,
it's almost like he's getting groceries.
It seems like a very small little,
uh,
like a puddle of with fish in it,
you know,
like they just taught him how to do it.
They're kind of cheating.
Yeah.
That's cheating.
The other orangutan was doing it hanging
over a flowing river like he was.
He was really figuring out as he was
going along.
It was this guy there and he's like,
fucking picking at ropes.
This is a puddle.
Right.
It seems like this is something new or
something.
Yeah,
right.
It seems like something they did for
science,
like they figured out a way to teach him
how to stab those fish.
Like if you just teach them that that's
where the fish are and you get it with a
stick that's not as impressive.
That's like you can teach a dog to do
that.
Well,
I mean,
I think I've seen birds,
I think it's birds that use that there's
some video of a bird like putting bait
down and then catching something with
it.
Like other creatures,
you know,
use bait to fish.
There are others that do it.
I've seen that too.
Yeah,
I've seen birds do it.
Um,
don't,
uh,
orcas do it to have an orchestra on it.
I don't know if they,
I didn't know they use bait.
Yeah.
Why do I feel like orchesis I've done it
too.
Yeah,
there you go.
Look at that smart guy.
Look at that.
Yeah.
It's really interesting,
right?
Yeah.
He just sits there and waits.
He waits for the fish to come near the
bread.
He's like baiting.
Like how did he figure it out?
It's did.
Did he see something,
do it or did he like innovate this
himself?
He a real good question.
Taught them that.
And this isn't even like one of the most
clever birds like ravens.
Ravens are the most clever.
Yeah.
It's got to,
gives bread.
It goes too far away.
See it gets away and he's like,
no bitch.
Nobody rides for free.
Bring them back.
Keep it right there,
right.
They,
they tried to move away with it.
Got Too far away.
He's like,
no,
bitch.
They're right here.
Have you seen.
I'm sure that that just snatched that
fish.
That's such as like,
what in the fuck just happened?
The thing about it is it snatched it up
and here's the thing.
That bird is not that much bigger than
that fish.
And it did it like it was nothing.
That's how creepy birds are.
Hooky snacked them and just walked away
with it.
Like no big deal.
It's like you have an like a small puppy
in your hands.
That's how I walked away with it.
I mean bigger than a puppy.
Like that thing's bigger than his head.
That's like a full sized dog.
Oh yeah.
For.
But I'm saying like
the way he held it was the way you a
puppy,
like you'd have no problem walking with
my light,
but that thing is,
you know,
probably 25 percent of its body weight
and he's mostly feathers.
Right.
Take away all of his feathers.
That fish might be at the very least,
might be like 15 percent of its body
weight.
Yeah.
Have you ever heard the idea of like a,
you know,
like we smack a,
uh,
an aunt or something,
he smashed Nat and that Dan has no,
no idea what.
There's no way that could possibly
comprehend what has happened to it.
Like when Irwin,
that you know,
you have a line of ants going into your
sink or whatever,
that line of ants,
they can't comprehend what you are like,
you walk by the line of ants,
they have some instinct may be to run
away from you.
A lot of times they don't even run away
from you.
He turned the scene on kill like 30 of
them in a second,
but they don't,
they can't,
they're there whatever way they used to
think they can't process it.
Right?
So death to that ant it,
it's going to be processing its
extinction in some way that we can't
even understand.
Right?
So there's this idea from my friend was
telling me that I'm the same way when a
human dies,
what we process is like,
oh yeah,
he got in a car accident,
man.
What really happened was some kind of
like hyper dimensional event that we can
only see one tiny piece of that looks
like a car accident in the way our minds
process,
the thing being wiped off the face of
this dimension is by like,
oh,
car,
red car wreck.
But really there's like all these other
levels involved.
So it's like maybe some hyper
dimensional entity just squashed your
friend.
And the way it manifested is like,
oh,
a car wreck.
It was a car wreck.
But really no.
That's just the way our brains process
that event from where we're at currently
in the,
in our ability to like comprehend
reality.
People listen to this.
Does that mean I can text and drive?
Texting and driving is easy.
It's fine.
That's the way they see when they see
you doing that.
They smash you.
You know?
Maybe it's just an accident.
What maybe death.
No,
maybe the accidents or just accidents.
Maybe it's not a hyper dimensional being
squished down on you.
Oh man,
it looks like things are not like that
man.
But we don't.
I mean really we,
uh,
we don't,
we don't know.
But that did the same way these chimps
are like doing these things at times
seem like pretty cute.
Really cute.
In the same way like,
you know,
there is this idea that we're going to
sort of go,
God,
I wish I could remember who explained
this.
It's like,
okay,
human existence up until the point of
flight was completely based on like
getting,
like you would climb a mountain and then
you could see the ground,
like you're from an airplane,
but that's pretty much it.
Climb up a tree.
I guess you get some altitude.
You can see this whole new perspective
on what look like from a high place,
but you certainly couldn't get the
perspective of flying through the air
and looking down at all this stuff that
formerly in front of you is like looming
over you.
It's like when I,
uh,
you know,
I have two little dogs,
adorable door,
have a little babies,
but you picked them up and like for you
it's no big deal,
but for that dog it seeing what's on top
of the fucking counters man,
it's like,
doesn't see that.
Usually it's looking up at everything.
So it transforms it's reality a little
bit.
So flight transformed human reality and
this intense way and now the satellites
floating around our planet if
transformed it even more because we see,
oh shit,
yeah,
we're on a planet where like it's a ball
that were floating around or a flat
earth or whatever.
But uh,
but the,
uh,
so in the same way,
the next,
the next sort of lift off is to somehow
rise above the time space continuum.
So that time itself becomes an object
instead of a thing that we're stuck
inside of that's the next big liftoff
and that there are already things that
are,
see time as an object instead of,
as a river that were currently being
rolled around in.
And for them we look totally different.
So that's the next.
That's what like maybe Mckenna was
talking about the idea of the time
machine or the singularity or whatever.
Is that like once we figure that out,
I know there's never going to be a
fucking time.
He said no,
it's insane,
but that theoretically it's possible.
You know,
people do say it.
It could be possible like there's no
necessarily.
There is no reason for us to be stuck in
the current way that we are.
At least that's from the fucking a
documentary I saw when I was super stone
four years ago.
Like they were saying you could use the
power of a star or something to.
Yeah.
I'm trying to remember who was German
mathematician.
It was like a German mathematician that
theorized about the time machine time
machine would have to be.
I want to say the machine would have to
be like as big as the solar system to be
spinning at the speed of light and the
transversus access or something.
That's it.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Insane.
But it's like,
it's not.
I mean,
obviously for where we're at right now,
this isn't a feasible option,
but if it's possible and we exist in an
infinite universe,
then why wouldn't things have
potentially figured out a way to,
to get beyond the time space continuum.
So like,
you know,
we're looking for aliens inside of time
and space,
you know,
but maybe there's like the thing we
should be that we're looking for.
We don't even have the technology to
scan outside of past,
present and future because that's what
we're in right now.
These things are like way outside of our
understanding of what,
um,
of what this even is.
We can't even fucking see them.
Like the ants can't see us.
Like we can't even see him.
We couldn't talk to them and aunt can't
talk to you,
you know,
I saved to be from my swimming pool and
I swear to God,
it seemed like it was thanking me.
Like I pulled it out.
Were you one to 10?
How,
when am I not have is the question.
But I pulled,
I pulled the,
uh,
I pulled the bumblebee out and I put it
down.
I was like watching it,
it's really cool,
you know,
it's like dried itself off and went
through this whole thing.
It's like watching a dog dry itself off
and then I,
and then it did this cool little like,
I swear it was like a little dance in
front of me,
like this weird little cool little
bobbing dance thing and then flew away.
I'm like,
did that fucking be just like thanked me
or like,
was that like some form of attempting to
communicate with me?
I mean bs certainly communicate with
each other.
There is communication among insects and
I don't know if they're aware that we
exist,
but if they talk to each other,
isn't it possible they might try to talk
to us.
Did I ever tell you about the uh,
the time on fear factor where the bees
communicated with local bees to tell you
that I didn't tell.
You know,
this is a fascinating moment because
there was a guy who was a beekeeper and
what he was doing as he was a,
it was at the sage brush.
Sage brush rent.
No,
I forget the name of the ranch,
but it just burnt down in Santa Clarita.
This big ranch they used to film TV
shows out there.
Um,
they put these people,
they put them,
they attached them to like this,
this rope and then they made him stand,
like connected to this pole and they
covered them with bs,
like covered them from head to toe with
bees and they had to stand there for a
certain amount of time.
Some people didn't get stung at all.
It's really interesting like this guy
really knew some people got stung.
I got stung just being around them.
But this guy really knew how to take
care of these beats is really like I was
covered in bees at one point in time and
you just stay calm and eventually blows
them off you with smoking shit.
Anyway,
while they're doing this,
he's got his own.
He's a beekeeper.
So he's got his own hive.
This local group of bees came over and
they met in the sky above us and all of
his bees went up to talk to all those
beats and he said,
we gotta get Outta here.
We have to stand back and let them work
this out.
We have to stop filming with,
stand back and let us work this out.
So it was me and my friend David
Horowitz,
who was a producer show.
We were looking at each other like
they're gonna talk it out like what the
fuck?
And we're sitting there watching these
bees above us just getting together.
And they were literally trying to sort
out who these new beads were,
what their plans were on fear factor,
man,
can you get me on that show?
Are you in Sag?
Crazy dude,
that's crazy.
It was really interesting and it lasted
for about a half an hour,
if I remember correctly.
They talked it out for half an hour and
then the other bees went their separate
way and then everybody figured out.
Everybody knew where everybody belonged.
Like those tiny little itsy bitsy
pinhead brains had decided these are not
their friends.
These are their friends,
this is where they belong there in this
traveling hive.
Yeah,
for some reason
is in the middle of Santa Clarita right
now.
It's not.
I mean,
all the levels of communication
happening around us at any given moment
are.
It's astounding.
We can't deal with it.
Like it's just too much to handle.
So we sort of get focused on our own
little lives as human beings or
whatever.
But fuck man,
there's a lot more going on.
I mean,
just that,
you know,
that if that's happening with bees
there's didn't.
It's probably happening with everything.
And so then we're in this like,
and we talk about this a lot,
but that means we really are in a matrix
of intelligence and we've just decided
to focus on this one the way that we're
doing it right now,
you know,
which is a pretty uh,
it's sad in a weird way because we do,
you do cut out.
You cut yourself out of a whole other,
uh,
community.
That's what one of the things I like
about,
like the native American mythology is
that they,
uh,
you know,
it seems like they had less of a
distinction between humans and animals.
It was like,
these are our brothers to.
I'm confused of what you're saying
though.
You're cutting yourself out of a
community.
Like what do you mean?
So it's like,
okay,
like,
let's just take it from the human love
you.
A lot of people,
they don't even mean to be,
but they're snobs,
right.
So they'll see humans snaps,
right?
So a human snob is exclusive,
So they have this exclusive relationship
with the world where they allow into
their periphery or in their circle of
friends.
I'm letting you into my circle of
So I have this tight circle of friends
and then other people based on whatever
their particular metric is for
determining who they want around them,
you know,
shit snobs are the ones who will happen.
You know,
there's people who happen to only be
friends with successful people.
It's like they're only friends with
like,
like celebrities and their own for like
weird.
That's a weird coincidence out of that
APP.
Holy Shit,
I don't understand what happened,
you know,
so there's that which is like for them
they want to interact into,
in this particular,
like part of the societal ecosystem,
which means they're excluding,
excluding,
excluding all these other fucking
people.
Right.
And so the moment you stop your,
you started experimenting with not
excluding people as much as you can.
It doesn't mean you let annoying people
around or people who have their don't
have your,
your good intentions with you around or
whatever.
You sound like you're giving advice to
stuck up Hollywood elites.
No,
I'm giving advice.
Just not.
It's not just in Hollywood.
It's like it's the elites in general.
There's actually some book I heard about
it and read it.
It's a really cool idea that would just
like the Galapagos Islands here.
We have these beings that have evolved
in a certain way because they're
completely separated from everything
else.
It's fascinating to see.
So in the same way,
there's a kind of economic galapagos
that happens with wealthy people,
which is that they only get around each
other and so they start mating within
their own circles and they started
exchanging only information that wealthy
people have.
And so this creates a kind of hybrid,
a weird new form of human being,
which is the elite wealthy class,
not a new idea.
The kings and Queens would only like
fuck with him blood lines and stuff.
I use an intentional form of like wealth
eugenics or something.
But.
So,
uh,
but anyway,
what ends up happening when you're doing
that is you end up cutting off all these
other forms of information that come in.
And then also you start living according
to a pretty ridiculous fucking idea,
which is that all these other people,
whatever they're doing,
whoever they are,
whatever it is,
you know,
that's just not really worth it.
Like,
what does that person really have to
tell me that I need to hear you know,
what it is?
Or is it that they feel like they can
get along with those other people
because the other people going to
understand them because people do find
like minded groups of people and hang
out together and if you're like some
super wealthy rothschild guy and you
become friends with some weirdo painter,
dude,
I mean,
how much do you guys have in common?
It doesn't mean you have so much in
common,
so much.
Really.
Fuck yeah,
you do,
man.
You have the human condition.
You have that gravity.
You're both dealing with the
gravitational field.
He wrote in a fucking body that's
goddamn melting down with the
progression of time you're a.
you're probably going to have to.
Both of you are going to have to bury
your mom.
You're going to have to bury your dad.
You're both.
There's so many.
There's a lot of things you have in
common,
but they would have to completely open
their mind up to accept.
All these things have to change the way
a person thinks and you have to change
it in essence who they are.
Right?
And some people just don't have any
desire to do that.
Well there's the problem.
And what's even worse is when that is,
when that kind of idea is the.
The is like encouraged when that's like
looked at as like,
oh this is just a totally normal way to
be.
Yeah,
just the club up Kanga town were cheap
shit.
It's like,
so that exclusivity,
even from a human perspective,
cuts you off to all these.
A lot of data.
Admittedly some of that data is probably
going to suck,
but a lot of the data is going to be
you're really fucking good information
that can make your life better.
Stuff's gonna come to you that you would
never expect when you stopped being a.
When you reduce your exclusivity.
So in that same way humans as a species
are exclusive,
right?
We are.
We place ourselves as the top of the
food chain,
human beings,
and underneath this is all this,
all this incredible biomass filled with
all these other forms of life that we
have managed.
Many people have managed to reduced to
being some kind of meat machine or
vegetable or vegetable.
Exactly.
Or plant life,
whatever it is.
It's all life.
And,
and,
and anytime you start talking about like
I,
I'm not positive about this,
but I feel like I can with
this plant in some way.
Like when I'm watering my plants,
I swear to God,
man.
Some little piece of me is like,
I think they know I'm watering them.
Like I think there's an awareness here.
I don't know if it's really either,
but it does feel interesting.
Yeah.
I've been in grow rooms before.
There you go grow rooms or like it's
like you walked into a room full of
happy aliens.
It's really what it's like.
Hey guys,
doing it really feels like you're saying
hi to all these plants.
It might be a hundred percent bullshit.
It might be 100 percent in my
imagination I might've concocted out of
thin air.
But going back to what you were saying
earlier about ants and the system that
ants live under and bees are.
These bees can communicate with each
other through pheromones and some other
way.
I mean,
I don't know exactly how they're sorting
out who's who and which.
Yeah.
Which clan belongs in what part of the
woods or you know who the fuck that was,
but the thing that we know about human
beings is that there are signals that
are around us constantly,
that we can't detect wifi and radio and
television and satellite.
All that stuff is broadcasting around
us,
through the air,
around us constantly and we can't detect
it and we also know that all throughout
nature of these animals that are blind,
there's animals that can't see.
There's worms.
There's all sorts of things that have no
idea.
You're there no idea that you're
watching television and there's no no
idea that you're about to get in your
car.
They don't even know what the fuck a car
is because they don't have the senses to
detect it.
Yeah.
Why would we assume that we hit the
fucking bonanza with the senses and
we've got it all down.
I don't know.
Ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
There's probably like.
I mean,
I don't know what those quantum
physicist guys are up to.
I think.
Didn't they say that they were up to
like they believe there's more than 30
different dimensions now.
We used to think it was 11 and now
there's some schools of thought that
it's like 30 dimension.
Fuck knows it could be infinite,
but the point is these could be worlds
that are in our,
in our midst,
just in a nonphysical sense.
At the same way,
ideas are nonphysical the same way.
Imagination is nonphysical the same way.
Like you know,
certain forms of communication.
You're just saying something to someone,
right?
I'm looking at you,
I'm telling you I love you and you're my
friend.
It's a nonphysical thing.
It gives you a physical reaction like,
aw,
thanks man.
I love you too.
Yeah,
we're friends that that's some sort of
weird nonphysical energy exchange.
It's not just as simple as,
you know.
Oh,
two people showing affection for each
other to friends,
showing each other.
Love that.
There's something else going on too.
That's it.
Yeah.
There's A.
There's an energy exchange.
There's both.
People get happy.
When I tell someone I love them,
I get happy too.
They get happy.
The whole everybody boosts up.
It's like a very underrated thing.
Telling your friends,
oh,
it's shocking.
Like when you're not even supposed to do
it,
but like again,
because we live,
this is why so much what we live in
is like very advanced,
but so much of it as like ridiculously
barbaric and primitive.
That to tell your friend you love them
can be a shocking
Ari shaffir still stammers alright,
I love you dude.
He goes,
Oh Joey Diaz,
you know,
I love your dog.
You know,
I,
Joe is like the most loving guy of all
time.
Eddie Bravo is a very loving guy.
Well,
you know,
we know a lot of loving people,
jobs loving.
I think we are love and,
and the,
the thing that I've been thinking lately
or just playing around this idea is like
what if I have all these different
versions?
I don't quite know the right way to get
it out.
But like so imagine like directly behind
you is a window that opens up into a
universe where everything is made of
love,
right?
And you're standing in front of the
window blocking that White,
right?
You're standing in front of the window.
And so like the human condition.
Again,
this is just a thought experiment and
admittedly a very high thought
experiment that I had,
but I can't get it out of my head.
So,
and I've heard Rom Dass give different
versions of this too,
but the.
So the idea is like,
here's this window opening up into this
alternate.
I don't want even want to call them
alternate universe.
The actual universe.
I guess it's kind of like Plato's
allegory of the cave to,
but you're standing in front of this
fucking window blocking the love.
Your ego is right.
Your ego is.
And so the more opaque your ego becomes,
the more you allow yourself to become
less and less of a thing stuck to
anything at all.
The more the light from that universe
shines into this one.
Right?
So when you're with someone who's like,
I love you,
I really love you.
They've gotten over their ego enough to
let the light from that window.
They just kind of like managed the let
that light shine through them for a
second into this dementia,
which is why it's so shocking and like
maybe why babies are so entrancing
because there's.
There's no ego there.
They're just a pure blast of love or
dogs in the same way or cats or anything
that loves you is so incredible because
what they actually are are like windows
are portals into their reality of what
our universe is,
which is love and so if you're blocking
the window then that means that like
you're mostly living in a world of
shadows.
It's like a person who's like very
egotistical is like living in a shadowy
world.
Do you spent way too much time at
burning man fry your brand?
I didn't spend enough time Friday,
right?
Shotgun windows,
love living things.
Are you starting your cult?
When I joined?
I want to join.
Can we join each other's?
I was just thinking when you were
talking about dimensions,
like is that an egotistical point of
view that we have,
that there is like a portal to another
dimension and is it really just that
these dimensions are constantly around
us.
We just don't have the ability to access
something like they're there all the
time.
Maybe that's like legitimately why no
one like the Fermi paradox,
you know,
the Fermi Paradox,
which is um,
if there's so many stars,
so many planets were there,
all the aliens,
where's The fucking aliens?
Maybe they don't.
Maybe they get so smart that they never
do that.
Like maybe no one does that.
Maybe we're,
we're liking this rudimentary thing,
like these stupid Fox are still,
they're still making metal dicks and
trying to fuck the sky shooting rockets
up into space and they're landing people
on is they're still doing it that way.
Like they,
they lack the ability to transcend space
and time and to just pass through other,
through other dimensions.
It's like as a species we're like a
crazy
person and a bus station staring at it's
at his hand and being like,
where are the aliens?
I don't see the aliens in my hand when
it's like all he has to do is look up
and he's surrounded by it
and you know the ultimate mind.
Fuck when it comes to the time travel
right now,
the ultimate mind fuck when it comes to
time travel is that one day they are
going to have a time machine and it's
probably likely it might take 100,000
years.
Who knows how long.
Think about when was the first tool,
like what was it a couple hundred
thousand years ago.
The data now,
I think it was I think the first tools
or somewhere around and have to look at
my calendar.
I'm not sure.
So from the first tool to now,
a couple hundred thousand years,
I think from now to a time machine,
if we stay alive,
if we don't blow ourselves up,
we don't get hit by an asteroid.
We keep improving.
They're going to figure it out and the
day they figured out what becomes crazy
is then all time travel from any point
in the future to that moment is possible
and to any place else on the scale,
see the ideas that you could only travel
where there's a road so once the time
machine is invented,
time ceases to be linear and everything
happens all at once.
Right?
Like literally anyone can come back to
any point in time and go back and forth.
You could smack someone and then you go
back in time before you smack them and
kiss them and then go back in time and
smack them and they'll go back in time
and kiss him.
You could pull their pants down,
you can pull the pants up and do
whatever the fuck you mean.
You literally could go back and forth in
time and it would have never happened
and you'd be communicating with the same
person once it happens.
So once it does happen and people have
access to it,
which that access,
like everything else,
whether it's cell phones or automobiles
or anything,
the accents,
the access starts in a limited way or
very few people could afford it and then
it becomes worldwide.
Did we talk about directed Panspermia
already as it related to time travel?
No,
I don't think so.
So it's like the idea of Panspermia mean
intentional like aliens.
Yes,
exactly.
So the idea is like,
okay,
uh,
I,
so I know this idea where you need the
road to travel,
so we need to build the road.
So what's the.
So let's say I do invent the technology
for a time machine,
which basically means I have point a now
I need to point B,
right?
So the point B A,
I've got to get the,
I've got to get the further out.
The point B is I guess the more,
the more,
the more powerful the time machine would
be.
Right?
So this is the idea of direct parents.
Sperming as a means of time.
Travel is assuming you are the super
advanced species than what you do is you
create these genetic,
these,
you create like Dna.
You create a kind of packaged thing that
when it lands in the right environment
that you could live in,
has the tendency to evolve into a
technological civilization that will
build a time machine that is actually
point b for your time machine.
So you released from your planet just
infinite blasts of this,
a DNA,
and you know that when it lands on the
road and then the seed finds the right
soil,
it's going to grow into a technological
tree that at the end of its growth is
going to flower with your point,
be the end of your time machine.
So if you were this kind of interstellar
traveler then for you,
you would send these seeds out into time
and then the moment of time that they've
got to the point where they built a time
machine for you,
it seemed like it happened instantly.
There's your point b.
You don't know what it's going to lead
to,
but uh,
you know,
it's going to be at least a habitable
planet because you've developed this,
uh,
these,
genetic machines to only take root and a
planet that you could live on.
So what we are are these genetic robots
that are compelled to build technology
because we're opening up the point b in
some kind of interstellar time machine
and that's what the singularity is.
It's when our creator masters come
through the time portal that we've
opened up on this planet and say,
Oh,
hi.
You did it.
Yeah.
It's pretty interesting as it seems like
it works.
Seems so science fictiony though that if
we really got to a point like imagine if
our civilization and gotten to a point
where we could transcend space and time
and travel through the universe and you
go to any place at any point in time and
even drop the seeds of life on a planet.
What does that term that they were going
to use on Mars?
Where the,
the uh,
what is it called?
What's the term when you take care of
that?
For me,
yes,
thank you,
and that they had done this like and
then they're gonna come back like the
silver surfer and fucking like,
I don't think so.
I think we're them.
I think we are them.
I don't think there's anything else.
This is what I think,
and I think this is a ridiculous way to
look at it too because a,
I don't know and I'm talking shit show,
but I think it is entirely
possible that we're number one,
meaning that we're the first.
We're the first.
We were the first of all these things to
achieve this state and that when these
things achieve this state,
they they either blow themselves up or
they keep going and they become more and
more advanced,
but I don't think it happens very often
and I might be wrong,
I might be totally wrong,
but it hasn't happened anywhere near us.
So let's pretend that the galaxy that we
look at right now that we can see.
Let's pretend that's the universe.
What if we find out that out of this
galaxy of hundreds of millions of stars
were the only intelligent life that
drastically narrows the possibility for
intelligent life everywhere else in the
universe,
except for the fact that the universe is
infinite,
which means that not only is there
intelligent life in the universe,
there's a Duncan trussell somewhere in
the universe.
Not only is there a Duncan trussell,
but there's a Duncan trussell that said
everything that you said in the exact
same order with every pause,
every time you dribbled piss on your
toilet seat and you all take care of
that later and you shut the lid.
It did that to the exact t an infinite
number of times throughout space and
time,
so like not only is there one of you,
but there's an infinite number of use
and then an infinite number of
possibilities left and right that you
could have gone different paths.
You can take it.
That's how big the universe is.
That's how big infinity is,
but that doesn't mean that anything's
ever gotten smarter than this.
This is the only thing that we know
that's gotten this smart.
It might be this is the only thing
that's got the smart because something
had to be the first thing that got this
smart.
It didn't happen unless it happens
simultaneously.
Like we're saying that it happened with
a bunch of things,
but let's call that thing the same thing
in different places.
It's not like there's a gray alien with
big black eyes and a giant head,
a little skinny neck that reads your
mind and flies through magnetic fields.
Right?
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about you and I this
thing,
this thing might exist an infinite
number of times all throughout space and
time,
but let's call it this one thing.
This one thing.
This might be the first time anything
has gotten as advanced as this one,
so it's like the term,
the simulation as they're using is base
reality like this is base reality and
not there.
The statistical probability of this
being based reality is somehow a.
it's more probable.
This isn't based on reality,
but yeah,
it is a probability that this is base
reality and there's also a probability
that this isn't based on reality like we
did.
You know,
you get to roll the dice on that one.
I like,
I who knows,
I mean it's impossible to,
to really like at this point we can't
prove that this isn't the default base
reality that the entire universe is
experiencing,
but my guess would be that no way man,
this is like a.
I think it's more realistic that we're
in a fucking,
like a novelty farm,
like some kind of technological novelty
farm.
Like it's like A.
I mean to use human terms were like,
Eh,
I mean if you could simulate a universe
and then create intelligent anything
Cynthia,
intelligent beings that are particularly
cynthiana intelligent beings that
matched you,
your species,
duplicate yourself even and then run
that duplication an infinite number of
times in this server mechanism or
whatever you have in your super
computer.
And then like,
you know,
you just set time to loop a.
It is faster rate as your computer would
let you.
So at night you just like let it run in
the morning you wake up and it's like,
oh fuck,
look,
hemingway.
Huh?
That's interesting.
They entire works of Hemingway just got
generated in my universe simulator by
one of the simulated creatures that I
had in there and it's a very prosperous
job.
You'd be like a novelty farmer or
something in the same way they've got
those fucking big coin things that are
like constantly grinding,
like make bitcoins,
you're fucking making universes and
inside the universities the universities
are making planets and the planets are
making technology and the technology is
being a.
every single whatever your morning
happens to be.
Whenever you wake up you're like,
oh cool.
We've got,
oh that's interesting.
That's a new form of teleportation.
I haven't seen that before.
It's a way to like harvest information
from a kind of living ai or something
like that.
You know,
it seems like it'd be a very,
a really smart way to kind of like
gathered data or to create not novelty
events.
I mean just for the pure entertainment
of it.
Like if you had a way to like access
like five,
like for you it's like,
you know,
right now we download a movie,
it takes like two minutes,
five minutes.
What?
Depending on your connection in the same
way like you wait,
five minutes in a universe is born and
dies,
and throughout that it can pick out an
interesting moments like,
look at this.
Oh look,
here's that moment where in that planet,
uh,
the world war three started because
fucking Russia wanted to like secure
Syria and we didn't want it to happen.
Wow.
Look at the disaster.
What?
We already have examples of this in a
rudimentary form and all these new
universes that are being created in
these online games.
Piggy back Lee.
Yeah.
What are those games,
Jamie?
What are the,
what are those games called?
Do you know the name of those games
where they create different worlds?
Like,
Oh yeah,
it's called procedural generation and
you're talking about the no man's sky.
The game that everyone got angry about
what they get angry about it.
Well,
they got angry about it because the,
the summation of the anger is just
because something is gigantic doesn't
mean it's entertaining.
Right?
And so you ended up getting in this kind
of feedback loop because if you're going
to procedurally generate and infinite a
year or a semi infinite universe with
all these different planets and stuff,
then that means you need an ai that you
can procedurally generate that's also
going to procedurally generate,
you know,
what we consider to be a game like,
interesting storylines and things to do.
It's just,
you're just creating things.
Right,
right.
Well that's one part.
The other part that people get mad about
is the apparently not even apparently
you can see like,
people get so mad.
God May,
you never piss off the gaming community
that's just like don't fuck with them
man,
because they swarm in and it's vicious
and brutal.
Like I was playing the game and really
enjoying it for at least a week and a
half,
two weeks.
And I go on like Reddit,
no man's sky and read the comments and
I'd be like,
God,
you guys are fucking dicks.
This game.
Super Fun.
I'm on the best fucking time of my life.
I'm never going to play this again to
you out of it.
No,
I know in the game it just suddenly it's
like,
wait,
it got boring,
it got boring and it got,
you know,
for me it got boring for other people.
I know some people were saying you guys
are dicks.
When I was enjoying it,
reading their critique,
I get it,
but really it was like reading the
critique of gourmet chefs far more
familiar with where gaming is at.
You know,
these are people who play games all the
time and know it and like have very high
expectations.
But anyway,
the point is yes,
it procedurally generates this
incredible universe but it ends up
getting kind of boring or something like
that.
But yeah,
procedurally generate like we are in a
procedurally generated universe that is
producing novelty events which may be in
the universe that we are being
procedurally generated out of as a form
of currency or a form of entertainment
or a form of something we don't even
understand yet.
But what could all I know is if I.
If there was a game called universe
creator run your computer and your
universe will at some point generate
sentience wife that at some point we'll
start generating technology that at some
point you'll be able to like watch and
possibly using your own dimension.
Then I will be running that.
If I was a company,
I would definitely be running that
software for sure.
I would want that to exist just for pure
capitalism.
What's better than like having a never
ending stream of inventions coming from
your universe simulator that you could
then market in this dimension.
I think there's something weird that we
do to where we look at things that we
can generate with a computer versus
things that sort of exist in the real
world and we look at them as coming from
different sources.
Something that man makes versus
something that just happens and because
of we look at it from different sources.
I don't think we recognize that.
It's kind of the same thing.
Like there's a long process from a star
exploding to a human being being born,
but they're all connected.
But star exploding is necessary for the
development of.
Of the carbon based life form on the
earth.
Right?
So this,
the elements that make us the star had a
blow up,
like there's this long,
but we don't think of that as like being
made because it takes too long.
We decided we're going to call it
evolution or natural selection.
Yes,
but by defining of these things in that
way we've.
We've failed to look at the thing for
what the thing is with.
The thing is forget about whether
evolutions real or creation of Israel.
That's nonsense.
That doesn't mean anything like whatever
is doing it,
it's doing it and it's doing it from a
star blowing up to a person talking
about a star billowing up to his friend.
Yeah,
like right now.
that's right.
This,
this is all made like whatever you've
made as been made by this process.
Any great painter and the architect who
built the most incredible buildings,
you were made.
This whole thing is made right and
you're making things too,
but those things aren't any more
significant than trees that all this.
The whole thing is nuts.
The whole thing is somehow or another
getting more and more complex,
more and more involved,
more and more aware,
faster information sharing between the
things that matter,
things making more and crazier and
better things.
But all of these things made by a star
explosion,
right?
Yeah.
Are,
I guess like if you want to get
technical,
the.
So when you say made it starts it and
employee.
Okay.
Right.
So you,
I mean,
it's a process,
right?
I mean,
man,
I think this,
I think we're probably like,
Bro,
we're,
I really do think that whatever this is
is like,
is literally made in the sense of like a
maker.
Like it was really think there's a
I think it was individual,
an individual.
I don't think it's an individual,
but,
and I don't think it's force.
I think it's the uh,
yeah,
uh,
create something that's very creative
and I think that it's.
Or it's a source of creativity and I
think that it's,
you know,
I mean I'm a fuck it.
I'll say I'm a theist man.
Like I pray,
I area sounds.
Have you punching?
I wake up,
talk to them.
I've fucking,
look,
I,
I just love to pray and like when my
life gets better,
when I pray and I just love it.
It,
it's,
I mean I fucking,
I,
you know me,
I don't have to know you too.
So I enjoy.
So when I sit.
So when you say,
well,
what is it an individual?
I think it's like there's lots of
different ways of saying it in every
single way of saying it falls short of
what it is.
Now.
There's A.
I keep telling you about this guy,
man and I.
One day I hope you pick them up.
There's a Buddhist teacher named Chogyam
Trungpa who says,
so I'll like getting in an argument with
Chogyam Trungpa,
like if he heard me spew that bullshit,
what he would say his weight.
So when I ask you,
is it an individual?
Is it a thing?
Is it a person?
And you say,
I don't know man.
There's no words for it.
Then at that moment what you've done is
you've taken your confusion and you've
put it on an altar and you started
worshiping it as though it were your
God.
Your ability to not articulate the thing
is not an indication of the existence of
a thing,
but it's more the indication of your
laziness because you want to like deify
your a confused,
passionate emptiness.
It's something like that.
There's a great for it.
And one of his books that is,
that's a great quote,
echoed through my fucking ever since I
changed passionate emptiness exactly
years ago,
Courtney love song,
confused,
passionate emptiness.
But,
uh,
so that being said,
I still,
uh,
the,
I think you should do experiments in
reaching out to the transcendent as
though it were possibly an embodied
thing that was a lot smarter than you.
And if the result of the experiment is
nothing,
if you just feel embarrassed or dumb or
you're like,
why the fuck am I praying?
Why there's nothing,
then who cares?
You lose nothing.
But if the results of the experiment is
even as a placebo effect,
you begin to experience a shift in your
subjective reality.
Then I think it's worth continuing those
experiments and seeing like how it
unfolds.
Well,
let's take away that definition,
the placebo effect,
because if you have in some way decided
to meditate towards,
um,
towards the objective of communicating
with the great love that runs the
universe and somehow know that benefits
you,
that's not a placebo factor.
Right?
That's,
that's a shift in your consciousness
whether or not it's validated by the
existence of the thing.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
It's still a shift in your consciousness
through what appears to be a decision
appears to be a decision that you've
made to gravitate towards God.
Yeah.
Gravitate towards love.
No,
I've always had the problem whenever
people talk about intelligent design or
a thing or a deity and this is my own
problem,
I automatically think of instead of the
universe,
like says that there's a universe and
then there's this thing over here,
like right next to the universe,
it's like,
oh,
I'm just gonna sit here and make the
universe.
It's a stupid way that I look at it.
It's completely my own.
Like you can grow up or you can just
sort of form these ideas in your head
about what a deity is and then those
ideas can be little prisons when you try
to define the universe.
So my defining the universe as the
universe being this thing that this
thing is created and it's sitting over
here in this other thing like is it in
the universe?
It does it,
does it build it from the universe?
Like where is it?
Is it next door?
Have a condo next to the universe.
Like what does it have?
Like how is.
Is it a part of the universe?
Is it or is it that the idea of an
individual is the wrong way to look at
it.
That if you look at all the life on
earth,
right?
Yeah.
It seems that it was a lot of things in
nature that are fractal,
right?
Insurance exists pretty much everywhere
you look and when they start looking at
subatomic particles and you realize how
deep they can go and how small they can
measure things and then you look at the
size of the universe itself.
You look at the size of galaxies and
black holes and just the vastness of
space and the ability to measure.
I think they measure 13 point something
billion,
light years since the big bang.
All that madness,
all that craziness that they're there.
They're trying to.
I think by looking all that and all that
stuff,
by looking at the vastness of all this,
we.
We define it in this way where there's a
dunkin over here and there's an aunt
over there and there's a,
you know another animal over here,
but inside of all of us are a bunch of
different animals that are all little
tiny ecosystems.
Right?
Inside every person.
There's not a single individual life
form that's a person.
Every person requires all this life
inside of it.
He lie living in your body and all sorts
of gut flora,
all sorts of things that are not you,
but there are you because you are a
system or a system just like your
neighborhood's a system.
Just like the rain forest is the system.
I'm sure all the people in the rain
forest that are hunting with bows and
arrows and really looking out for
Jaguars,
I'm sure they don't think of themselves
as a system,
but there are life system.
That's how life balances itself out both
in your gut and in the jungle and in the
mountains of Montana and in the savannas
of Africa.
These are all system life systems and
our vision of life systems is that this
life system is contained to this planet.
This is it,
but this planet,
everything on this planet,
right with the life system that's
contained on this planet is all bathed
in oxygen,
right?
It's all these gases and the elimination
of those gases does not mean that you're
not connected to all the other things
that don't have those gases.
You take those gases away,
you go into space itself.
You're still fucking connected to that.
You're still a soup.
You're a part of an infinite soup of
space and you just like a subatomic
particle that blinks in and out of
existence that they can measure.
It's moving and it's not moving.
It's there and it's gone.
Just how small the life form of a planet
is in comparison to the mass of the
universe itself,
which might very well be just like every
other fractal.
The bigger you get,
the more it represents the same patterns
over and over again in larger scales.
That's right.
The entire planet could be a subatomic
particle particle in the cell of an
organism that lives on another planet.
Your entire
universe itself,
or if you want even go deeper into it.
Could the entire universe could be some
kind of like a synaptic pulse in the
brain of an entity just having a dream
like so,
which is the synaptic pulse of another
entity,
but it's also having a dream and it's
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and there's no end.
This is the,
uh,
this,
this is the one of the first and the
emerald tablet.
This chemical,
you've seen that.
We've probably talked about it.
Oh,
it's the emerald tablet.
The emerald tablet.
The book.
It's the,
it's like this out chemical text that's
like this super condensed.
A really old.
Yeah.
It's really fucking old man.
And then I'm going to try to say that
it's the,
it's got a great name that I always say
it wrong and I always get corrected.
And so I'll say it wrong again.
The Emerald Tablet,
um,
uh,
there it is of Hermes trimester or
something.
But if you open it up,
open up the emerald tablet and then
hopefully we can see what it says on it
because it's like a,
there it is.
Okay.
What is the first one?
Say,
okay.
To certain with error.
Certainly most true.
So you just said number two,
that which is below is like that which
is above and that which is above is like
that which is below,
um,
to do the miracles of only one thing.
And as all things have been in arose
from one by the mediation of one.
So all things have their birth from this
one thing by adaptation.
So anyway,
it's like,
so it's all the shit that we were just
talking about.
Somebody had already figured it out.
Well,
it's so,
yeah,
it's like the,
it's the,
it's evidence that other people have
been as high as we are enough to put it
in a tablet.
Dude,
they didn't have podcasts.
They used to have to carve shit and
tablets a lot of work and write that
down.
We got to find some emerald man.
If you had to write all that on bark.
Yeah,
a lot of work.
but this is kind of the,
like the,
all these chemical ideas.
I guess it's like,
it only makes sense that if we see these
fractals all throughout nature,
we can observe them here that are ideas
that we can only observe subatomic
particles that that's the whole
universe.
Like it's probably infinitely smaller
than that by the way.
Here's what's cool about that.
Is that as a translation by Isaac
Newton?
Yeah.
So.
And he was really into this shit man.
Like Newton was fucking nuts.
Like he was doing was asexual too,
right?
I think he was like these.
I don't want to say because he's like,
it's A.
I don't know if he's a sexual.
If he was.
I think a lot of these guys,
they were fucking around with mercury a
lot and like it was like messing with
their heads like,
oh,
I'm sure.
Yeah,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
God,
forgive me,
everyone out there,
I don't,
but go to Newton and the occult.
Go Back and look at the occult section.
It's really interesting.
I don't think a lot of people are aware
of the fact that Newton was deeply into
the occult.
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of those scientists in the deep
thinkers back then were,
they were checking on all sorts of
different things.
Well,
I mean,
checking
on it is one way to put it,
another way to put it is like,
it may be that some of these people
figured out ways to directly communicate
with this intelligence that I,
that,
that I certainly believe in and there's
through mercury poisoning me.
Yeah.
Maybe mercury is the way to,
you know,
it's fecal bacteria,
personal life,
because you were showing his personal
life stuff there.
I want to make sure I'm right because I
said that he was asexual.
I read some weirdness about the way he
viewed sex and wasn't a Christian as
well.
A pretty hardcore Christian.
I don't know what kind of Christian he
was like that's a.
that's a whole lot.
I mean Christians and big words
never married.
Although he was once.
What does it say?
Once claimed that he is.
Oh,
although it was once it was claimed that
he was engaged.
Newton never married.
The widespread belief that he had died
of a virgin has been commented on by
writers such as mathematician,
Charles Hudson,
probably a hater economist.
John Maynard Keynes,
keens hater and physicist.
Carl Sagan.
How dare you,
Carl?
Well just said that.
I just said fuck me.
You did say why?
Why are you talking shit about nudity?
Not even talking shit about.
I'm just fascinated by individuals that
are brilliant beyond beyond the norm.
Like Tesla who was also like,
yeah,
a weird guy sexually fell in love with a
pigeon,
you know the whole deal and that was
completely out of his mind,
but yet insanely brilliant.
Beyond insanely brilliant.
I think that's what happens is like what
we in by the way we call them out of
their minds,
you know,
where meanwhile like,
what are we doing that makes any fucking
sense?
Well,
yeah,
they're crazy.
I got it all figured out.
Look what I'm doing.
I'm sitting in a fucking podcast studio
talking about the infinite universe.
It's like we're all like the idea that
any,
there is a kind of a pattern that's
like,
oh yeah,
that's the same pattern right there.
Well,
I think these people,
they uh,
they do make contact and I think,
you know,
we talk about like,
uh,
one of my favorite,
I think you told me this,
Joe,
one of my favorite,
a Ufo conspiracy theories is that
Roswell was a real alien crash and that
we can chart the evolution of technology
from the Roswell alien crash.
That technology is actually some kind of
alien virus that came in through what
Roswell and is now spreading through art
through history.
Now.
That's the most popular conspiracy
theory when it comes to the creation of
like the transistor at Bell
Laboratories,
which is in New Jersey.
There's an air force base outside of
bell laboratories and bell laboratories
is supposed to be where they examined
all the parts that they took from grant
from the Ufo and they flew it to Wright
Patterson air force base and then they
took all the stuff out of it.
It's,
it's so fantastic,
dude.
One of the many things I love about you
man,
as you are like the library of Congress
for this stuff.
Whereas in my mind it's just like a
murky swamp when I try to remember.
It's like if I pull you can you can in
detail expound on these things you like
photographically memorize them.
I think it's really cool and so
therefore I know that you were the one
who told me this and I think about it a
lot.
It's a really cool idea,
but I think it's funny because for us
we're like,
okay,
the way we would get technologies by a
metal craft shooting into the earth and
then we're going to take that and make
technology.
Whereas I think the real alien
encounters that happen throughout
history,
the Ufo encounters a Ufo for,
for,
for lack of a better word,
a Ufo flies through the consciousness of
Isaac Newton and Isaac Newton.
Tesla,
all of the great inventors have this
spontaneous idea what they're like,
wait,
what?
Wait,
wait,
and so the alien technology is actually
not something that is necessarily has to
be matter,
but starts as a thought form that then
gets sort of produced through the
spinner rack of the particular inventor
that like allows it to come through
them.
You know
this very thing in an interview today,
the exact thing.
Cool.
Because we were talking about ideas
possibly being a life form or ideas
being a form of like creativity and
ideas being a form of life that forces
the change on an environment.
Forces the change in,
in,
in a civilization come from ideas,
the ideas.
Creativity is responsible for
everything,
including this microphone,
the Internet connection,
the building we're in,
everything we're wearing,
everything.
The car you drove to get or all of it
comes from the imagination,
from ideas from creativity,
and the initial burst of imagination
comes from where we don't know.
It might be a life form,
it might be as much of a life form as a
physical thing,
like,
like a person
or it might be the uh,
okay.
So like a eric,
I don't know,
you see in the,
it's never actually happened to me,
but like a plane flies too low and like
the fucking trees or like when a
helicopter is landing,
the trees blow.
People have to hold their hands over
their ears.
Right?
So maybe when these like transcendent
objects enter into our time space
continuum,
shit,
tons of people start having the very
same idea or different,
like brilliant ideas that are actually
just the,
uh,
the sort of impact that this craft as it
passes through our planet or passes near
us or whatever that means from the
dimension that they're in.
Maybe that's the impact that it has on
our consciousness is the sudden
origination of these incredible ideas
that end up creating massive shifts in
our society that that that's because if
you look at like Tesla where he got his
ideas and I don't know about Newton,
but a lot of great inventors there.
It's not like their ideas came as they
were sitting at the whiteboard
calculating and then they had a Eureka
moment,
like they had dreams
with Tusla literally was claiming that
he was getting some information from
space.
Yeah.
He thought he was getting information
from space.
That's right.
Yeah.
I think.
I think you're onto something John Lilly
too,
but he was so fucked up all the time
though because he knows space lily was
shooting intramuscular ketamine and then
climbing into an isolation tank all the
time.
LSD,
isolation,
attending the academy and injections.
That was towards the end like,
eh.
I think.
I think in the beginning it was LSD.
It was LSD and there was like a.
and it was like.
I think he got to the point where he
recognized that maybe his physical body
was actually getting in the way of of
what he actually was,
so we just sort of wanted to mountain
the nothingness and it was sort of
troubled by this thing.
I've got to keep coming back to this
fucking day.
He's ready to get out of it.
Not as a suicidal way,
but just like the way that a a something
that has molded has to discard.
He so far removed,
I don't want to say gone because I don't
think he's wrong,
but he was so far removed from the
average human being in terms of like how
bizarre his paths of thinking had gone
and what he was trying to accomplish.
He was trying to mean he's a pioneer
interspecies communication with
dolphins,
dolphins high on acid.
He would get high on acid.
He could eat me wandering asset to
dolphins.
I didn't know that part of the story.
Do you know that his research on
dolphins was all canceled because the
girl who was a scientist was jerking the
dolphin off.
That got his research cancel.
Yeah.
That was one of the things that got the
the project where she was living with a
dolphin.
I like this story you're telling me is
it's the story of the fucking luckiest
dolphin,
like,
you know what I mean?
Like not only.
I'm saying if you get caught as a
dolphin,
it's not great,
but if you are going to get caught by
the monkeys and you don't end,
you end up in a place where they kept
giving you acid and jerking you.
US.
The sounds off makes when you drug them
off.
Can you imagine if that Dolphin got into
conversation with a seaworld dolphin and
they're like,
wait,
what?
Wait,
You jerked off dude,
I'll do flips for fat kids.
Fuck this man.
Fuck this Gig.
She jerked you off.
How often?
Everyday.
Yeah,
and she kind of likes it.
I don't have look good.
I don't understand how that got his
experiments cancel because it's pleasure
because we're so puritanical.
We like through a scientist.
It's not.
It's makes sense.
This dolphin was severely distracted.
It was horny all the time.
She would jerk the dolphin off,
the dolphin could relax and then they
will do it to work,
but the dolphin was always horny because
dolphins,
like a kid,
you know,
dolphins,
like a,
an 18 year old kid,
18 year old kid with a boner.
It's just so distracted.
Good luck trying to get them to do work.
So she just thought rationally.
First of all,
she's a scientist.
She didn't think there was anything
wrong with sex and she definitely
realized that there was a problem in her
research where this dolphin is dealing
with too much desire to get rid of them.
So she's whacked him off,
whacked him off,
and got back to work.
That's a very smart and pragmatic way of
looking at it.
The problem is she told people about it,
like over cocktails,
you know,
is there a fucking boyfriend?
He ruined it.
He was like.
So anyway,
I jerked off.
What was the Dolphin's name?
It's a good question.
I bet.
Like when he came to visit her at work,
like he started getting five,
she was choking off the dolphin like it
was looking at him.
Weird.
No kidding.
Right.
Fucking.
Imagine what a.
The other thing is the dolphins,
they were trying to get dolphins to say
human words.
Yeah.
But they can't.
They don't have any lips so they can't
make those sounds.
So they would do their best to make
something close to it,
but you know,
they have those high piercing,
shrieking sort of sounds that they can
make.
Do you know man,
that's the.
She's
even the thing.
Here's what would have happened.
If they could have gotten the dolphin to
talk,
they would have canceled it because the
only thing you would say is off again
off again.
Wait,
what did it say?
Have you seen the video?
I don't mean to change the study.
Have you seen the video of the cro
telling someone,
fuck,
you know,
could do you know that video if you look
at is so fucking funny man.
Like this guy,
this guy,
it's like he doesn't insult the cro.
The Cro really like snarks him.
I hope you can find a cro literally
says,
fuck,
look at this.
Watch this.
Hello?
Hello.
That's crazy.
I don't hear anything.
Watch over.
Got The big head.
Whoa.
It's like insult his beak and he's like,
fuck cute.
Whoa.
See if it was any other animal.
I'd go,
no,
what?
Right.
But they're so goddamn smart.
Yeah.
You didn't want like fuck year.
Make Fun of my fucking beat.
Did you ever see the raven that starts a
fight between two cats?
No.
Dude,
can we see the Nepalese?
I put it up on my instagram.
This is some crazy shit.
Some raven flies over to Kat Fox with
him a little bit.
The cat tries to get away from,
um,
the cat likes.
Turns around real quick and the raven
jumps away and then the raven flies over
to another cat is on another rooftop
sweat.
How he does this.
He literally starts a fight between
these two just hanging out like,
down.
Damn fucking bored.
So he flies over there and fucking,
I guess it's not a raven,
is that a raven?
The Crow Crow.
But why is it looked wide?
Is that the reflection of the sun on him
and now could be at.
I don't know what happened.
Anyway,
so he flies over there.
He gets near the cat and he irritates
the cat and then he flies over.
It,
gets near the other cat.
Look,
he's getting behind him.
He irritates him.
He fucks with them.
He's fucking with both from literally
like he's fucking with him on purpose.
Look,
he's getting really close.
This is.
It backs up.
He's getting really close.
He fucks with them.
Look,
he's literally fucking with that cat.
Awesome.
He keeps.
He keeps poking at him.
He's getting right behind him.
The cat turns around a swing at him,
so he's agitating the cat.
The cat jumps on the other and he flies
over there and he's often away from them
while they're duking it out.
They fall off the fucking roof,
beating the fuck out of each other.
He flies to the ground and he's watching
them like he literally instigated and
started this fight that he's prodding
them while they're fighting.
They fall into a hole.
They're beating the shit out of each
other.
Dude.
That birds like,
dude,
what's the bird in their ear with them?
Fucking crazy.
Right?
And that's the bird is the devil to
Raven.
Yeah.
That's so raven.
Ravens are always taught in BC Tannic,
right?
Well,
yeah.
I mean I guess are there.
They're like a harbinger of doom.
They're called.
There's a great word for it.
Psycho pumps is the word for it,
like animals that appear,
I think before someone's going to die.
Like crows.
There's a whole bunch.
There's Edgar Allen Poe.
The Raven.
Raven.
Yeah.
The Raven that.
Well,
I think,
you know,
I read an analysis of what that was.
It's like very,
very fucking sad,
man.
Check the dump.
They're never going to be happy again.
Oh,
that's it.
The idea is like,
yeah,
you're never going to be fucking happy
again.
Like ever.
Like you're.
You're like happiness is a dream.
Give it up.
The reality is that life is,
you know,
it's the usual kind of fucking drivel
that comes out of Pete,
and I don't mean to say trivial,
but sometimes the old happy juice isn't
coming out of the synaptic vesicles.
Vesicles way it should,
and you translate that.
It's like instead of recognizing that
your engine is running low on coolant,
you think that all cars in the world
must just run in some shitty way.
It's really,
it's,
to me,
it's one of the most beautiful things to
realize while simultaneously being one
of the most depressing things to realize
which is that so much of what human
happiness is,
is coming from these synaptic vesicles,
these little bubbles of Serotonin that
are getting dripped into our brains
according to our,
what activities we are partaking in,
you know,
and so
some people have.
The drip isn't happening.
And I would say that it's probably safe
to say that for Edgar Allen Poe,
if his brain,
if you could say the synaptic vesicles
or the vagina of the human brain than
his word dry,
arid,
just just fucking chafed synaptic
vesicles.
He was depressed and nothing's coming
out man.
And like,
I know what that's like because,
uh,
anyone who's taken Mtma,
if you've taken Mtma and it felt the
Mtma related depression and extrapolate
from that three straight years of that
unrelenting numbness that comes when you
don't have enough of the happy juice up
there and then you're going to start
writing shit like never more.
Also,
it doesn't help that,
uh,
his fucking wife.
I think at one point she had a.
What was the name of that terrible
disease?
Tuberculosis.
I think it was tuberculosis.
She has some horrible lung disease and I
think she was playing piano at this,
a party that he threw and she just like
exploded blood all over the piano.
Like she just caught the big spray of
blood.
So he had a rough life at Graland Po.
He's a fucking alcoholic,
you know,
he had a crazy go that to that,
that makes depression.
I mean,
it doesn't help,
that's for sure.
Nothing hinders your happiness.
Like crashing your system every night.
Ugh.
Um,
you're essentially slowly poisoning
yourself if you're really a in a
drinking all the time.
Oh,
not good.
Not Good.
Not fucking good.
There's so many better options out there
for it and on that Pod,
that's illegal,
but no.
Yeah,
I just think that people would benefit
more from a two for marijuana instead of
making you more confident,
makes less,
makes you more alert,
more aware,
more objective.
It just makes you a nicer drug.
It's nicer,
like in terms of its effects in terms of
the behavior of people that are on it.
Just a way nicer drug.
Hey,
I tell you man,
like all this fucking shit coming out
about Hillary Clinton.
The thing that really bummed me out the
most man was that fucking.
She's like anti marijuana like that
really?
Like,
that really gets to me man.
It's like God damn it because like I was
going to do for her,
like the pragmatic Clinton vote,
you know,
like,
well trump seems like a fun guy to hang
out with at a party.
Don't want him around my nuclear
weapons.
Like Hillary Clinton seems like a,
uh,
like a,
a,
you know,
God just like the ultimate politician,
like the super evolved ultimate flower
on the Goddamn Po.
Barbara Bush of politics.
Like she's but God saw fuck out outright
in fucking check
Hillary Clinton,
and it's like God damn it.
Like she's rude.
Johnson.
What?
Gary Johnson.
Gary Johnson makes sense.
I mean,
he doesn't know shit about Aleppo,
but he doesn't know shit about a lot of
things.
I'm sure there's going to have to learn
if he becomes president.
Do you really think that?
Is that really your intention?
That's who you're endorsing,
endorsing him more than anybody else.
That's who you're going to vote for.
I'd vote outright in you about that
bitch.
Don't write in me right in back at your
ranch is right in back at your answer.
That's what I'm writing in reading
impact trenches.
Fine.
But I do think that,
I mean,
can we talk about this nonsense so long,
but her,
her insistence on working towards
marijuana and making sure that marijuana
stays a schedule one drug.
Yeah.
It's.
It's not just disappointing.
It's traitorous or a set of word.
Yes,
out of big.
Yeah.
It's big.
Traitorous make it better word.
It's not traders.
Shitty trader is.
You could say traitorous sounds wrong.
It sounds like a dinosaur treatise.
Hillary Clinton trade a syllabus,
but I think it's,
it's not just not doing your job to
serve and protect us and to lead us.
It's not only is it not doing your job,
it's doing the opposite of your job.
You're doing something for profit and
for you,
you've made a connection and through
influence you've decided to do something
that you know for sure doesn't help
anybody.
It keeps people in jail.
That's all you need to know.
The key people in jail part,
it's all you need to know.
More people were arrested from marijuana
than for all violent crimes combined.
That's so fucked up.
It's insane,
but that's the problem is that it's a
business.
There's a giant business and arresting
people and putting people in jail,
keeping people in jail,
enforcing laws.
There's a business in that.
It's a huge business.
We don't want to think of it as a huge
business,
but anytime a huge business drops off
and it's going to drop off whoever
you're.
If you're in that business,
get out now because you're like
blockbuster video.
You motherfuckers right?
You're not going to make it.
You mean the prison business?
Yes,
the prison business and the drug
business,
that dea business,
the arresting people for marijuana
business.
Anybody who's in the arresting people
for marijuana business,
you might as well be selling Betamax.
I hope you're right,
man.
You can't.
It's not.
It's not going to work anymore.
You can't keep arresting people for
something that everybody does,
so I had to give it up without.
If she's saying if flight the next
president,
she's definitely gonna be the next
president is saying that she's going to
continue this prohibition to the bankers
that were paying her to give a
presentation then,
and this is the person Obama's endorsing
and Bernie Sanders is endorsing it.
Just like that.
Look,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't.
The more I look into all this shit,
the more confused I become.
Like I start.
I tried to like go a little deeper into
it,
like looking up the Clinton Foundation
and then like checking out the charity
websites that like talk about the
Clinton found that or give it a rating
or whatever.
And it's like,
well it definitely doesn't it.
Like there's a lot of misinformation
coming from both sides,
but the most,
the one I trust only because they're
like a left leaning super liberal
website.
The huffington post called,
there's an article in there saying that
Hillary Clinton Foundation's gross is
the name of the article and basically it
says the foundation itself,
if you look at the tax returns,
since it's an operating foundation,
all the bullshit of they're only giving
like six percent or 10 percent of the
money to charities is wrong because they
are doing shit.
They are doing stuff.
That foundation goes into the world that
has worked with AIDS.
So you can't villainize the entire
foundation,
but what's fucked up is the Clinton's,
when they go to give talks to people who
then donate to the foundation,
they get paid and that money separate
from what goes to the foundation.
So when Hillary Clinton goes and gives a
speech and then they donate to the
foundation,
the amount they pay her for the speech
doesn't go to the foundation.
So that goes to the Clintons when Bill
Clinton and it's hundreds of thousands
of dollars for an hour speech.
Yeah.
Right.
So that's where it's like,
that's where the corruption is and
apparently there used to be some kind of
law that if there was even the
appearance of corruption and politics,
then you had to change your operating
procedures,
but that apparently got changed in the
Supreme Court or something.
So now you,
you could.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
And like last night at the debates man,
when uh,
when they asked her about the Wiki leaks
shit,
which is real,
like it's however the information got
obtained,
it really doesn't fucking matter.
But.
But I mean it matters.
But the issue is the information itself,
right?
So when you watch that faint where she's
like,
you got it from Putin,
it was amazing to me.
That was like,
God damn it,
like trump,
there's a really great chance right
there for you to be like,
did Putin send those emails?
Was He writing your emails?
Because let's talk about the fucking
emails and then we'll talk about Russia.
But he liked spun off on this weird
thing.
It was a really like associate baited
them.
She fucking baited him.
She's a master thought.
She's so good at playing him.
She's so good.
It's amazing to watch though.
He's easy,
but she's doing it masterful.
Well,
she is.
Well Mr Lee.
I guess that's like the one better
comfort that we have is that this person
who's going to become president is very,
very sophisticated when it comes to
manipulating people.
Sophisticated in a way that like,
God,
man,
I kept looking.
I kept trying to take pictures ever.
And you get up close to them,
dude.
Shit.
Her view,
someone needs to put together a montage
of Clinton fucking stink eyes.
Have you seen like how good she is at
given the stink eye?
Like she was looking because what's
crazy?
She was like looking.
She's looking at the camera,
like I'm trying to get pictures ever
because she's wearing the same outfit.
Kind of is the heaven's gate dude that
he liked.
Like it's Kinda the same outfits.
I'm trying to get a picture of it and
uh,
and she,
she keeps looking at the camera and
giving this like fucking stink.
I that felt like she was looking at me
like it felt like fuck.
She knows I'm trying to like do this
tweet about or weird outfits.
She gives a terrible stink.
I'm like,
I've never seen anybody throw.
I daggers.
Like Hillary Clinton camp man.
It's crazy.
Do you think that's.
Do you think that she's employing a
different strategy now?
Because their first strategy with him
was to kind of laugh when he would say
ridiculous shit and almost like take the
high road,
but now she's gone on the attack more
and now Clinton and Melania Donald shake
hands before.
Yeah.
Like there's all this,
all this stuff that's going on,
man.
It's different.
It's a different sort of vibe now
between the two of them as it ramps up.
I think she was like super effective
though and just taking the moral high
ground her.
Yeah.
Well I mean in terms of debate tactic
where here's trump my imagined.
I imagine like what it trumps strategy
meeting looks like is like people
sitting around eating cheeseburgers
doing blow.
You know what I mean?
They're like,
they're like,
trump's already making deals for his
next TV show.
He's like,
he's like,
fuck,
whatever.
Yeah.
The president thing,
they don't care.
They're like,
you know,
he probably is getting fucking calls
from poot and they're laughing.
They're like,
alright,
I gotta go,
we gotta do this stupid fucking debate.
Like,
you know what I mean?
And I think if you look at a Hillary
Clinton strategy meeting,
she's like sitting in some kind of like
God dome surrounded by CIA agents who
are like,
we've done a thermal analysis of Donald
and here are the moments that you should
hold still and at this moment we
recommend that you say this and then
this and then this.
Like she goes through the hole that
they're like,
oh,
he's definitely gonna bring up the Wiki
leaks here according to our
psychological analysis and also some of
the DNA data we got from one of the
cheeseburger crumbs that fell out of his
fucking mouth.
And one of these rallies is like he's
going to react to this and like she just
memorizes it and it kind of alien way
sits there and just does it.
Like the fighters I'm sure.
Like I remember when you were like,
when I realized,
because I don't know at the time I
didn't know anything about fighting,
but then you were explaining how like
their,
they have these insanely deep combos if
this person does this,
they have all these moves like 19 moves
deep that like there's incredible.
So I think she's like that.
Like she has like if he does this,
you do this and if he does that then
this,
and then that.
And then that.
And they've done it all with like a
government team of psychologists who
fully analyzed him and know how to
fucking set him off.
And she did it last night.
She did it in every single fucking
debate and it's not like she's the one
who's coming up with that.
She's got a team of the smartest,
most manipulative people on planet earth
who baited him in to the fucking
elections in the first place.
You saw that email,
right?
Where they picked the three candidates
that they wanted to empower,
you know,
or to like build up,
which was trump.
What's his name?
Cruz.
Ted fucking cruise.
Because he's also fool because he's a
fool and the other,
the sweet guy,
the docker,
Rubio,
not Rubio,
Carson,
you know,
so like they pick the three biggest
fools days.
They're like,
all right,
let's pump them up.
They pump them up.
The King of the fools made his way into
the fucking president.
Somehow.
They're like,
are you fucking kidding?
We got trump.
We've got fucking trump.
Trump.
Oh,
hold on,
let me go to the trump file.
Oh my God.
Listen to this audio of him talking
about graphing fucking girls.
She's like,
okay,
great.
Let's use that to hold onto that for a
while.
Yeah,
we'll do that on the day before the
second debate.
Yeah,
let's do that in the day before the
second debate.
You know what I mean?
I think they gave it two days.
Yeah.
Two days to two days to build and then
of course they are probably working on
like,
you know,
months leading up to it.
They're like,
let's find every single person that
claims Donald trump grope them or that
were groped by Donald Trump.
Anyone who's willing to claim Donald
Trump grope them.
Anybody wants to get on TV?
Yeah.
You guys failing and I.
But I have a feeling.
I mean I don't,
I don't know for sure,
but my guess would be that if you wanted
to find people who said,
yeah,
trump grabbed my pussy,
it wouldn't be that fucking hard.
It's not like you're looking for bigfoot
pretty easy to run them down I guess,
but so,
so it wasn't like a hard thing to do.
It's a breadcrumb trail.
Very simple,
very easy.
And so it's like when you realize like
that,
then you start feeling this weird
compassion for him and you're like,
oh my God.
Even with all his like,
maliciousness and like weird
pervasiveness and stuff.
Ultimately he,
they,
he's like a fucking bowl.
They got put into a Goddamn ring with a
matador has been doing this kind of bowl
fighting for like 30 fucking years for
better,
for worse.
And he's,
we're watching what we saw last night I
guess.
And what's interesting about it,
a big part of what's interesting about
it is he came really close to women.
I mean,
he still in the neighborhood of winning
plus or minus 11 points or what that
means is between now and how many days
do we have until the election is 21
days.
Listen man,
lot of crazy shit can happen in 21 days
to shift people's opinion.
No,
but apparently again,
from all the now look,
man,
I try to get it right.
Don't say any of that stuff because you
don't even know if it's true.
They're all just talking on TV and they
brainwash and all of us to let us think
that they know who the fuck's voting.
They're not talking to you.
They're not talking to me.
They're not talking to Jamie.
They.
I don't think they know nearly.
You know?
I don't think it's a massive cover up at
all.
I think a lot of what happens in the
polls does reflect how the United States
feels,
but there's no way it could be 100
percent accurate because it's not.
It's not pulling 100 percent of the
people.
And I think part of the problem with
those poles is once you read the results
of the polls,
Hillary Clinton is a head by 16 percent.
Everybody just starts saying,
well,
Hillary Clinton's got it in the bag.
I've seen the recent polls.
And you even start thinking in voting
towards that goal.
Like people who might have voted for
trump go,
I don't want to waste my vote.
I want to be on the winning team.
You know,
there's a lot of that
I think really though,
man,
like if people like what that they
affected that actually has his people,
he might have been terrified of trump
being president.
They're like,
she's already had by 12 percent,
I'm not going to fucking drive out to
the polls to vote.
They don't come out to vote.
Like it would serve her more if there
was some collusion between her and the
media,
which according to the Podesta emails,
there certainly has been there.
Like you've got the of the editor of
politico,
you saw that one where he's like,
fuck it,
I'm a hack.
Yeah.
Crazy,
crazy.
So like,
I don't know if was the editor,
I don't remember which guy was it.
The point is I would,
I think it's a pretty safe bet that
she's going to be the next president and
I don't think that that data that we're
getting is necessarily some kind of
collusion between
not saying it's collusion.
I'm saying it affects the event itself.
I'm saying that even if you do
legitimately objectively pull a group of
people and you get a result from that
pole,
it's not really representative of 100
percent of the people.
But once you start thinking that it is,
and once people start deciding that it
is,
it has a massive impact on how people
vote.
Well,
I gotta tell you man,
before the fucking buses go riding
through varying neighborhoods and
scooping up illegal immigrants in before
that fucking abortion cops start
arresting fucking women for getting
abortions and before all the insanity
that like apparently he's going to do
starts happening,
that he trump that if he gets elected,
if he gets to the metal arresting people
for abortions.
Yeah.
He said that women should be punished
for.
That's one of the main,
one of his many fuck ups as he was like,
yeah,
women should be.
There should be some punitive.
The legal shit.
If women get a legal abortion,
that's real.
Look it up.
You could find.
It's like famous.
Yeah,
look it up.
Whoa.
He's like,
I really said that.
Well,
he said you look it up.
There's a whole thing.
Fine.
James James is going to look it up.
I didn't know that he had said those
words.
That's a crazy thing to say there.
Ask
someone for having an abortion.
Not for having an abortion.
It's like for a.
you'll see it's like enough that like
she mentioned in the last debate.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's hard to say too because a lot of
his positions on things,
you know,
or off the cuff,
like maybe he hadn't even considered it.
Somebody brings something up and he
talks about it and it doesn't have the
fucking kind of trump he said he was
miss.
I'll let you read it.
Okay,
let me read it.
Go back up.
Go back up please.
I'm trump abruptly.
Reverses course says women should not be
punished for abortion.
So what did he say?
What we're going to look it up?
What was the station?
There's been some sort of.
There has to be some sort of punishment.
He said women who receive unlawful
abortions,
I have not changed my position.
Trump said in the statement he said he
was referring to Dr.
super former illegal abortions,
not women who received it.
Okay,
I understand.
so he still believes that doctors who
perform illegal abortions,
there should be some sort of punishment
for them.
All right,
well that's not the same.
Wants to reverse roe versus Wade Rosie.
Yeah.
Rosie said that last night.
I said he would put it into three or he
said he would try to put in three
Supreme Court justices that would be on
that side of the.
The decision.
So it would automatically get reversed
was I think his exact words almost.
Man,
that's so tricky.
That's deciding what people can and
can't do with their body and it'd be.
It was.
Not that it's a baby,
it's not always a baby.
Sometimes it's a bunch of cells.
When it's 10 cells,
it's still a baby,
you know,
like you could get an abortion 10 cells
in.
Is that an abortion?
I mean,
I do not know.
I'm legitimately asking what time do you
get to tell someone that they can remain
pregnant?
But think of the irony that fucking pro
abortion.
Hillary Clinton is anti marijuana.
So she's like,
I can.
I'm going to tell you.
I know it's not our place to say what a
woman could do with their body,
but I'm going to fucking tell you what
you can put into your body.
I've,
I think it is the government's place to
say that.
It's like,
well,
what the fuck?
She's doing it for profit 100 percent.
That's the only reason why the banks
wanted to do it in the first place.
Wild.
Would the banks be concerned about
marijuana?
Are they in the marijuana business?
What the fuck is going on?
Why would banks want her to be for
marijuana laws?
That doesn't make any sense.
I don't get it,
man.
It's all a giant backed.
A lot of bankers love weed,
so it doesn't make sense,
a guarantee.
I know what it is.
It has to do with banks having interest
in pharmaceutical companies.
You know,
the company that makes fentanyl,
we've talked about this ad nauseum.
They're spending hundreds of thousands
of dollars in Arizona to try to stop
the,
uh,
the medical or not even medical.
They're trying to do recreational,
recreational marijuana from being passed
in Arizona because they know that it's
way cheaper,
way easier and way more effective pain
relief.
It's going to fucking cripple their
creepy ass business.
And guess what?
No physical addiction properties.
Some people get addicted to it,
but to the same people that
get addicted to a lot of stuff folks,
and it doesn't mean there's like
physical addictive properties to
marijuana.
There's not really a mechanism for you
to get physically addicted to marijuana.
The way you can get physically addicted
to painkillers,
even if there was,
it's not the government's place to say
you can't do this,
especially while they still have pain
pills and then taking money from these
pains.
Oh,
it's so gross.
What a fucking mess,
man.
It's like,
just to like this dream is like,
man,
can you imagine if the fucking
Republicans had come up with just a
normal dude?
Like if they just somehow come up with
one normal guy,
like a,
just a non religious nut and somebody
who like doesn't have like a checkered
past just to kind of balanced guys like,
well you need to work on the economy
like Mitt Romney without the Mormon
Shit.
If they had just come up with that,
they would have won by a long shot,
a long shot.
It's like this was the perfect chance
for them to get somebody in,
but it didn't happen.
They couldn't do it like the whole sit.
Their whole system was so screwy.
It's sad to you when you hear some of
the [inaudible] by the way,
man,
here's a news flash.
Not all Republicans are pad.
Like people think that a lot of them
have like some great fucking ideas.
Smaller government.
Not a bad idea,
but when you like,
here are some of the frustration from
like my fucking dad,
man.
He's a lifelong Republican.
He's a vet and he's,
you know,
he's like dismayed by all of this.
Like he's,
he looks at it from the perspective of
someone who's like seeing so many
different election cycles and to look at
like it's boiling down to debates that
have turned into the fucking jerry
springer show literally like this is a
fucking guy who spent two fucking years
in Vietnam by choice because he thought
he was going to fight for his country.
So these things mean a lot to him and
it's like to see fucking this fucking
barely.
And at least in the debates that I've
seen,
I don't,
you see barely anyone talking about the
fucking veterans.
Like no one's fucking talking about the
fact that the Va's fucked or that like
some of these people aren't getting any
of the medical care that they need.
It's like crazy.
They're up there fucking talking about
trump grabbing pussies are like Hillary
Clinton's fucking stupid foundation.
What about the fact that like people are
blowing their goddamn brains out?
Oliver neighborhoods across our country
because they made the decision to like
go fight in fucking Iraq and more people
have killed themselves than have died
serving.
Yeah.
What about that?
Why are they,
your veterans have killed themselves
than have been killed in war.
Can you imagine?
Like,
that's insane.
I have never let me.
What is the numbers?
I would like to know how much more it is
that more veterans have committed
suicide than have died in combat in
these wars.
That's,
that's,
that's unbelievably shocking to the fact
that they don't talk about
that at all.
Hardly at all.
And it's like to just imagine like.
And by the way,
here's another thing,
man,
one thing you don't hear about,
like we hear about like,
you know,
you hear about the,
uh,
you know,
you hear,
we do hear about ptsd a lot,
but like you,
I don't think people realize the impact
that ptsd as a family,
like the impact of your dad or your mom
being completely closed off because like
when you get ptsd,
you develop these crazy survival
mechanisms.
So you try not to feel as much anymore.
So you get numbed down,
you become an alcoholic,
you become a drug addict,
you,
you have difficulty expressing emotions,
you're a fucking mess man.
And like by the way,
with all due respect,
but you're not,
you know,
ptsd is a very difficult disorder to
have,
right?
So it's not just impacting the vet,
it's fucking the entire spreading out
into the communities and the
neighborhoods and shit.
And the fact that like,
I just imagine being in a family that's
been.
God that's so fucked up.
Suicide surpassed war,
other larger place.
Jim,
just 17 to 22 every day.
Make that a little large police.
Wow.
Look at that man.
Jesus Christ.
This is,
this is really incredible.
Forty six percent of the look at this.
The fighting in Iraq and Afghanistan
accounted for anywhere from one and a
three deaths in the military from 2005
to 2000,
10 to more than 46 percent of the deaths
in 2007 according to the height of the
Iraqi.
So during the height of the Iraqi
search,
more than 6,800
troops have died in Iraq and Afghanistan
since nine slash 11 and more than 3000
additional service members have taken
their lives in the same time according
to Pentagon data now.
So keep going down so we can find out
where that's it.
Wait a minute,
hold on a second then go back to the
bottom of that please.
It says more than 6,800
troops have died in Iraq and Afghanistan
and more than 3000 additional service
members have taken their lives.
So how is that the same amount?
Gook go back up to the title.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Is this a bad article?
Suicide surpassed war as the military
leading cause of death.
What that means is currently that
doesn't mean like all total.
I think this is an old article.
It's currently that which is,
you know,
but still.
Fuck.
That's so dire.
Yeah.
This is a couple years old.
Go and find a.
If you can please find a more recent,
because I think what they were saying is
suicide.
Suicide has caused more American
casualties than wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan.
There it goes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay,
so what are the.
What are the numbers there?
Jesus Christ,
veterans to explore experts estimate
that 17 of the 22 daily suicides
involving vets not enrolled in the Va's
healthcare system.
Cheese
27,258
of those we honored for their service on
this veterans day have died by their own
hand.
Twenty seven fucking thousand people.
Whoa.
What?
That's from.
How many wars?
How many,
how many years?
It's still people.
It's unbelievable.
Anyway,
man,
the whole thing saw unbelievable.
Right?
It's very believable.
Like what?
An empty,
empty existence to be having sent over
there when you're 17 years old and
you're fighting for a war that a lot of
people don't believe in.
You wind up killing people you don't
even know.
You come back off,
fucked up and ptsd it out and then you
don't get any help.
Yeah.
You don't get any,
any help because part of I think maybe
part of PTSD is you don't want to reach
out for help.
So that's like part of the disorder is
you're all numbed down.
So like,
yeah man,
not to mention you have many of these
people have brain trauma,
like they've got like there's a lot of.
Anyway,
I'm sure that if you're sitting in a
fit,
like if you're in a family,
it's been impacted by that and you're
watching the debates because you know,
for me like I do,
I will.
I watched the debates is a form of
entertainment,
you know,
to me it's kind of like there's
something in it that's like grim yet
hilarious and it's like interesting to
see this kind of unraveling of our
political system in this way.
But man,
it's like when you just spend a little
bit of time thinking about how the whole
machine is like impacting families in
the most fucked up way.
Man,
a lot of kids,
they don't know their dad has ptsd,
you know,
like they don't even know why their dad
is drinking so much or is acting angry
or unpredictable or seems fucked up.
They don't even know it.
They just think that's how dad is.
And then they like develop.
They began to imitate that behavior,
you know,
and then the next thing you know you've
got like this,
like echo of this terrible thing that
war is echoing out into,
into our communities and in India,
in our fucking in there everything man.
It's just so I imagine when you're
watching the debates and you're
realizing that these two people are
spending.
I don't know what percentage of time
talking about that.
I don't know what the percentage is
exactly that.
They've talked about veterans at all,
but you probably start getting really,
really,
really depressed when you're like,
well,
I guess that was just a bunch of
bullshit that we did out there for real
because these guys are barely talking
about it.
It's just a weird popularity contests
for them to get into this position of
power.
That's all it is and they're saying
whatever is popular in the moment and
what's popular in the moment is grabbing
pussies and email scandals and that's.
That's what everybody seems to be
focusing on because the war has been
going on for so long that people almost
numb to it,
and if you drudge that up,
it's not going to get the same emotional
sparks.
The current event sparked that we love.
We love a current event.
Spark right now.
The current events bark is grabbing
pussies and emails candles.
I went back and forth the other day
during the debates,
um,
post debate from CNN to Fox News,
CNN to Fox News,
just listening to the different sides
and how they talk about stuff.
It's so bizarre.
I mean,
you never are more aware of the fact
that you are being your pr propaganda as
being projected in your way.
Just blatantly unapologetic propaganda.
The CNN people aren't even remotely
considering the impact of her,
her,
the,
the controversy with the Clinton
Foundation,
her,
this wikileaks stuff that's come out
about the bankers and her trying to keep
marijuana and the illegal drug and keep
Americans in prisoned.
Therefore,
because of it,
none of that gets brought up.
Nothing.
Not a thing.
It's brought up the idea that 30,000
emails were about Yoga classes.
How much does this bitch take yoga?
How is that even possible?
Dude,
I've been doing Jujitsu for 20 something
years.
I don't think I have a thousand jujitsu
emails or I could delete.
I don't even think I have one.
I might have 100.
I might have 100 or 200 Jujitsu emails
that I could lead.
How the fuck is Hillary Clinton?
Nonphysical.
Hillary Clinton with her bite suit on
that crazy space outfit on.
How is she.
You're trying to pretend that you're
doing yoga all the time.
Come on.
That's insane.
Doing Yoga.
I
also like this sinister thing.
They did apparently John Kerry
manipulated Ecuador and the cutting
office.
Sanchez Internet connection,
you know,
so it's like on top of that they just
like shut him down there.
Like so like our country was able to
manipulate and now they're contrary to
shut the internet connection off of a
guy.
It's like,
you know,
you hear about how like who's the new
leader of creates Kim Jong Il was the
first wounds,
the second.
So like Kim Jong noon,
the South Koreans,
they like put propaganda weather
balloons in North Korea and the,
I guess the North Koreans to see this
shit and they're like,
what the fuck?
And then like,
you know,
Kim Jong wound threatens to like shoot
nuclear missiles into South Korea for
distributing information.
Like,
Hey,
you guys are in a fucking hell bubble
over there.
You know,
the world's not really like that.
They don't know that over there.
Right.
So in the same way a assigned has
started like leaking this information
was just like,
hey,
check it out man,
your politicians,
this is how they fucking work,
this is how they work.
And instead of us being like,
Whoa,
let's reform the system,
we had to reform this fucking system,
man,
you can't do that.
Like even if it is above the board,
like even if what you're doing is above
the board in some kind of weird gray,
liminal legal area,
it shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be.
Let's fix it.
Instead we're like,
ah,
this is that Vladimir Putin trying to
fucking manipulate our elections,
which by the way are not rigged.
How did he say that?
When our politicians are so fucking
honest,
why would anybody say that?
The very thing that makes these honest
people rise to power would be fucking
corrupt.
Too strange,
so strange,
so strange.
And it's like the,
you know,
the reaction we should all be having
should not be like,
I don't know,
anger at Russia.
Their reaction.
We should be having his anger at our
political class.
You know,
it should be.
And that was the sanches idea,
right?
That's his idea is like if we expose.
He wrote this essay,
I read an article about it.
If we expose the inner workings of our
political class and we show that the
level of deceit,
fullness that is involved in this game
of chess,
which now people are just saying,
wow,
that's just the way it works.
That's how it works in the modern world.
You've got to be cutthroat and you've
got to lie and you've got to trick and
you've got to do all this shit.
If we expose them,
then what that hopefully is supposed to
do is make them reform on their own or
create what he called a.
The idea is you want it to be very
expensive to lie.
You want to,
you want to and you and also he's
created a situation where all of them
are living in a terrible world of
paranoia,
which I think is kind of hilarious
because like a song has done to Hillary
Clinton,
what the NSA has done to all of us,
you know,
like they've,
they,
he has all this fucking data and she
doesn't know which data he has.
She doesn't know what he's got.
A lot of politicians have no idea what
wiki leaks has.
That's the strategy behind.
I think that's the strategy behind the
trickling release of this information is
because it's like the Japanese water
torture little drops so that every day
they have to sit and think,
fuck man,
they did.
They get those fucking pictures in the
Bohemian.
You know what the rumors are,
right?
Do you know the rumors about to release
that?
There's going to be a bomb dropped on
November first.
That's the super awesome conspiracy
rumor deluxe of the day that on November
first anonymous wiki leaks guy fawkes
himself,
someone is going to drop some huge
fucking information bomb that's going to
make Hillary Clinton is like,
they're the rumor.
Of course I'm must conspiracy theorists.
Gonna disqualify for the you the
election.
I don't even know if that's possible at
this point because she got away with
that email scandal.
Shit.
Like that email stuff would have put
anybody else in jail.
Right?
I mean I posted something on twitter the
other day about a soldier who took
photographs with his camera on his phone
of some inner workings of a submarine
and he's going to jail because of it.
Just took photographs.
So what she did was infinitely worse.
They're both government officials.
That soldier and Hillary Clinton are
both government employees.
Right?
The only difference being,
of course she's elected.
Yeah,
that's it.
I mean,
other than that,
I mean he works for the government.
He's.
But his responsibility to adhere to the
rules has way more consequence than
hers,
which she did with those emails,
like no one is.
No one is denying that it was illegal.
No one is saying it was fine and heard
crazy.
Talk about it being 30,000
yoga emails just exacerbates the whole
thing.
It's like,
listen,
if they're going to find out it wasn't
really yoga and then what?
Then what are you going to say?
What are you going to say?
Yeah.
There were some yogi emails.
There was two of them to Yogi emails and
then there's 28,000
about Bengazi.
Alright.
Alright then.
Then what happens?
There's 20,000.
Oh Man.
Using drones on Julian Assan made she
wanted a drone.
Him?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think I'm joking.
I'm not defending either.
These creeps.
They're creepy to me.
Both of them.
Give me the fucking heebie-jeebies man.
But like I do not.
Julian assange's you're talking about
trump and hillary,
right?
No,
I'm talking about that monster.
Julian fucking assigned.
We gives you the creeps.
No,
I'm kidding.
I love him.
I have a plan to help Julian Assan
escape.
I think I know a way to get him out of
that fucking embassy.
If you wanted to leave like I know how
you could do it because you know,
you see,
so here's what I would do.
So like,
you know,
you see him come out to that little
balcony and kind of look at ms dot sad
way,
like he doesn't have an internet,
fucking sucks.
So here's what you do.
Schedule one of those flash mobs were
10,000,
20,000,
30,000.
I'm putting my life on the line here.
Please fucking Clinton and trump.
Don't kill me for saying this.
I will only want everyone to love
windover.
Get like 10,000
people to gather around that fucking
embassy.
Wearing that guy fawkes mask the
anonymous mass.
They're all wearing the anonymous mask
and certain outfit.
Are you?
Do you have a side business in anonymous
masks?
What guy?
Fox business.
Duncan trussell dog guy.
Fawkes mask.
It goes to my foundation of show.
So the,
the idea is you get them to gather
around it and some kind of mask and
dress like Julian assange and then just
throw a mask.
So he liked jumps out into this mob of
people all dress like him wearing this
fucking guy fawkes mask and just
vanishes into the crowd.
That's a movie that's mission
impossible.
So yeah,
I think it would work with.
I think because he's got access to the
balcony,
it means you could get down.
You just got to pop a laddered up real
quick.
Everyone's dressed like fucking.
And not everyone looks like a sand with
the anonymous mask on.
Yeah,
look at that.
Pop right off of that fucking balcony.
The balcony.
So close.
Just dive into a sea of people dressed
in the anonymous masks and get just
fucking vanish in a time.
Shave your fucking head.
Get them face.
How does that Guy Sleep?
I mean,
wouldn't you be freaked out?
The fact that his door is that close to
the the.
I mean that's where the door is.
That's where the ground is,
right?
Anybody could just jump there and climb
in.
This guy is hated.
Hated by some of the biggest world
leaders ever.
That's his little tiny balcony.
You live in a little equity embassy in
the.
Yeah,
it's Sun London and he asked to stay in
that building.
You know how he feels when he's in that
building.
He's on foreign soil and they can
invade.
It is insane and he's been there for
four fucking years.
Not going outside.
You Know How that Guy Fucking sleeps?
He sleeps like a fucking hero when that
guy goes to bed,
he goes to bed in the way that somebody
who is like,
I'm actually trying to help my species.
You see them dance.
I know.
Pulled it up this anytime we'd pull up
Julian assange's dancing.
No.
So nothing wrong with them.
Nothing wrong with it.
It's just you have to,
when you see someone dance like this,
you have to always think God is a god.
He's a goth.
Yeah,
I mean there's nothing wrong with
dancing like that.
There's nothing wrong with dance like
that,
but you got to be aware of everything.
That's something to be aware of.
This is how massage dancing and he
dances by himself like this,
so that's another thing.
It's not just he's moving out into the
dance floor,
dancing by himself now.
Now let's,
let's be honest.
He could easily be on drugs,
which cases is all forgivable behavior,
definitely on drugs.
He may be on ecstasy right now or molly
or it might be stoned out of his fucking
mind on some pot.
Cookies are on acid or something,
but he's.
He's dancing and a very,
very strange what?
Goth dance.
He's doing a goth gothic dancing and
there's nothing wrong with it,
man.
Look,
I chant strange.
He's fucking weird on my other videos.
I mean,
people are weird.
You know,
there's nothing wrong with dancing.
Weird,
but you should know that too.
Listen,
man,
Kaiser View,
whenever I hear anything about Julian is
dodge.
I do think about that dance video,
which God forbid my fucking dancing's
were,
God forbid.
Yes.
There's nothing wrong with the way
dances.
I'm joking,
man.
People don't.
I put up a thing today about a flat
earth and people thought that I was
serious about the flat earth.
I put up,
put up this thing on instagram about all
the.
The evidence that you're being
brainwashed and one of them was if you
really believe that the sun is millions
of miles away,
how to tell if you're brainwashed,
do you believe the earth is spinning a
thousand miles an hour,
but you can't feel it.
You believe the oceans are curving
because gravity in air quotes,
but you can't measure it.
Right?
Leave ships disappearing over the
horizon or proof of the globe and not
due to perspective.
You believe that pilots would not have
to account for the earth curvature or
spin while flying.
Man.
Yeah.
This is.
Tell them at one time was getting.
I was like,
I was getting a massage and the massage
therapist with a flatter Arthur.
Oh No.
It was the past.
I mean it's like what's better?
It's like I'm talking massages sometimes
suck,
but like she say,
what's funny about it is as she's like
explaining flat earth theory to me,
I wanted to argue with her and then I
realized my understanding of cosmology
is so terrible.
I couldn't come up with a persuasive
argument against it because it's like,
well,
the conspiracy argument is the best
because you would think that everybody
would have to be in on it.
Everybody who's ever been apart of space
travel,
whether it's the Russians or the Chinese
or the Americans,
anyone who has ever been an
astrophysicist success to on it.
This was the best fucking buddy.
What was that was someone saying I was a
sellout because,
uh,
because of my flat earth hate and we
know where your checks were being
cashed,
they were being there.
I'm getting like I'm getting shut up.
Money for the round earth,
the earth.
God,
I'd love to see that meeting.
That's a fun.
I'd love to see that meeting were like
you and sas men are sitting with like
these reptilians and they're like,
listen Joe,
you know the earth is flat.
We know the earth angle at check in
front of you and then go and you go and
take the check next,
next,
next.
Yeah.
That's.
Come in.
Let me ask you something for real,
for real,
for real man,
Bro.
If you knew the earth was flat,
so I don't know how you knew like like
fucking Dana White and are the people
who run the UFC.
They were like,
look man,
it actually the first to tell you.
Okay,
but it can be broadcasting.
If let's say you knew the earth was
flat,
don't go too far,
but let's say the lizards did visit.
Let's say they did visit you.
What's your price to be a shill?
50 bucks.
What?
50.
50 is a good meal somewhere.
Get a steak.
Glass one.
I'll ask her a lot.
I don't want to die.
Look,
you guys are lizard.
The lizard people.
You're all powerful.
You're going to run this thing anyway.
Just 50 bucks.
You don't want them to think you're
unreasonable.
Oh,
he wants $50,000,000
or we just fucking eat him.
Dude.
I just eat.
I like fishing this stuff out of you
because it spawns youtube videos.
It's really funny for me being a
satanist.
Someone will to confirm with you guys
are Illuminati because you did that
thing at the UFC.
Are Illumina,
illumina?
I'm in the Illuminati.
I didn't even know I am in the Illumina.
It's great.
Is it good to get good benefits?
What benefits?
Yeah.
Okay.
Tell me later.
Tell me later about the benefits.
Maybe.
I don't know him.
Don't ask me my numerology.
Is I real?
Yes.
Ooh,
interesting.
What do you mean?
Why?
Are you a mason?
A Free Mason?
Yes.
Is there any other kind of and fucking
pyramids and then you kissed the kissing
part was probably one of the greatest
moments in UFC history.
That was great man.
Oh Shit.
Can I tell you something?
I just found out.
Yes.
Okay man.
This is actually
really cool.
You should research this.
Did I tell you about the cacophony
society?
No,
it's okay man.
So the guys who like at least partially
started burning man are called the
cacophony society and it was this group
of people that do the funniest fucking
things together and it's really
fascinating.
They call it culture jamming,
but like,
uh,
for example,
they do this.
If you ever heard of the salmon run.
No,
it's that they dress up and matt giant
salmon outfits and run the wrong way and
racist.
That's Hilarious,
dude.
Run towards the crowd.
They run the opposite direction.
So you'll see a marathon and salmon are
running like that is so funny.
That's so funny.
That's the cacophony going upstream.
They're high fiving people.
People let them go through that.
I'm mad.
That's good.
That's the cacophony society man.
They uh,
but these are the guys who started
burning man and chuck Palahniuk.
That's where he got the inspiration for
fight club because he was running for no
coffee society because he was in the
cacophony society.
He was,
he's one of them,
but like the,
their motto is you may already be a
member and anybody can start their own
branch,
but it's like really,
really funny.
Like if you look up all the stuff
they've done,
man,
it's really trippy.
Like they said,
uh,
they,
one of the things they did was they set
up clowns at every stop along the bus
route so that every time the bus pick
people up and picked up a new clown,
but the clowns wouldn't acknowledge each
other.
Like they just happened to be getting on
the same bus constraint.
It's cool though because what it did
like,
I mean I'm not going to try to get into
their,
uh,
their theory about it because they
actually have a pretty deep
philosophical like,
or it seems to be a fairly deep
philosophy that a lot of it's really
hard to understand for me,
but a data ism is part of it and this
concept at this thing called the zone
actually hocking based temporary
autonomous zone is kind of related to
this idea that you can create these
little bubbles that temporarily sort of
a where the normal rules of society just
don't exist in that moment.
And so people who get to be in that
bubble with you get to experience a kind
of respite from the never ending flow of
society which can produce like huge
changes in a person's life to suddenly
no longer be afflicted with the humdrum
normal day to day.
A materialistic consumeristic bullshit
that we call everyday life to create a
tiny little bubble where that doesn't
exist and where you're like,
there are two rules.
They don't.
I don't know if you even call them
rules,
but the rules are you don't do a
cacophonous event for money and you
don't do it to promote your religion,
so you're doing this for no reason other
than like subversion for subversion
sake,
so there's no.
The profit that you're getting from it
is just the incredible moment that you
find yourself in is salmon outfit
running the opposite way,
but what it does is it temporarily
disrupts the hypnotic trance that a lot
of people are in,
like when they're living,
you know,
you're just in.
This was on by design.
That's what they're trying to do,
or they're just having fun.
It looks like they're just having fun
running against the crowd of marathon
runners.
So salmon outfits.
Yeah,
that it is for fun,
but then there's a theory behind it.
It's not actually like this is something
that they've written out and
contemplated it and acted on.
There's a great book called Tales of the
Cacophony Society that I'm reading.
That's so fucking funny.
How long have you been around for a.
they've been around since the.
They were pre burning man,
so I guess they'd been around for like
mid eighties or something like that and
prior to that there was something called
the suicide club,
which was,
or they're an offshoot of this group in
San Francisco called the suicide club,
which was like an actual secrets society
that if you wanted to be a member you
had to get your affairs in order like
you were going to commit suicide.
Oh yeah.
It's really cool and like really cool.
But uh,
but then the cacophony society sort of
emerge.
Their history is fucking hilarious
though.
The history of them is so funny and like
if you look at like the early burning
man that the confidence we're involved
in whole Lee shit,
they have like a drive by shooting
range.
So like they would like drive in cars,
blasting it targets.
Dude.
They were launching flaming fucking
pianos out of catapults out in the
middle of the desert like they were and
people were getting hurt.
Man.
I wonder why,
but like they were like they were bad
ass.
And it sounds like if hunter s Thompson
started a religion.
Exactly.
That's a great way to put it in and I'll
tell you,
man,
he probably knew of them and if he
didn't know of them he would have been
like,
oh,
I'm one of them.
And like,
can you be,
you can be one of them.
You don't have to even join up.
You start your own.
But we started a branch went today.
Right?
When did we start one?
Well,
we just started a second branch.
I started a branch.
We'd,
we,
I say we,
I,
we will what's called the Ukrainian
branch of the La Cacophony Society.
And we a Ukrainian Ukrainian.
Well,
we had the last meeting we had our,
we sell.
We had our final meeting,
a Gelson's on hyperion.
So here's a meetings.
Well we had our last meeting so we had
the final meeting.
And how many meetings did you have?
All told one who's we?
Me and a bunch of people.
I just put it out on twitter.
Who were the people?
Me,
Brendan Walsh.
Uh,
and then like a group of like some other
people from burning man who I know.
And then just some people who responded
to the tweet.
But we all met at Galston in pajamas.
We met,
we met at Gelson's that we met at
Gelson's,
gnashing and imbibing bar and pajamas.
And then,
uh,
and then we did,
we did.
Uh,
so what we,
the plan was we met there,
we had drinks and it was automatically
the most.
It was so weird driving to do it.
I'm like,
well,
you definitely have wash your mind,
man.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Like this good coffee idea.
It's crazy.
I don't know why you're fucking doing
this.
So I,
I,
uh,
I ended up thinking like,
you feel crazy driving the Gelson's in
pajamas.
And so we,
uh,
we fucking get there and all of a sudden
the people at the bar looking like,
what the fuck is happening?
Like suddenly there's this group of
people standing at the bar and fucking
pajamas and then in your pajamas,
look like I wore captain America
Pajamas.
So fuck.
Yeah.
But then.
So then,
uh,
so then,
but then what we did is Brendan Walsh,
because he was like,
we had him give this speech because like
I was like,
everybody,
I don't want this meeting,
our final meeting to be caught up in how
Brendan Walsh ruined the Ukrainian
branch,
the La Cacophony society.
So let's just not think about that.
And then he gives a speech and he reads
the entirety of Tiger Woods cheating
apology.
Suddenly this dude in pajamas is reading
tiger woods,
cheating apology in front of a group of
people in Pajamas who whenever Brendan
would say one of like tigers,
weird apologies.
Everyone would applaud and then shush
ourselves at the same time.
It's a psych class and like,
shit,
I'm talking,
I'm talking.
And so,
and then we sang,
we sang fucking do you want to build a
snowman from frozen?
And then we fucking left.
And both.
Did you film it?
What we have?
Yeah.
We have to just film a film of this.
I have a film of it.
I'll send it to you.
I don't know where it is.
Not Online,
but,
but yeah man,
that's what we did in pajamas or
bathrobes.
We will tell stories of the good times
our society shared offer,
final toasts and sing.
Do you want to build a snowman?
Meet at gnashing and imbibing the
Gelson's bar.
Holy Shit.
Bring sleeping bags.
Yeah.
It's so ridiculous.
It was.
It was really fucking great.
We're going to do another meeting that
we're going to have you are.
Well,
yeah.
We're going to have a meeting of the new
board,
the new British new Ukrainian branch of
the La Cacophony Society,
but we haven't figured out what that is
yet.
But why is it new?
Ukrainian,
Ukrainian?
Well,
I don't know.
The whole point of the thing that,
which is really beautiful because I got
on all this shit happened because like I
realized like,
okay,
well burning man was the coolest thing
I've ever experienced and then I trace
that back to the cacophony society and
then I kept hearing this guy's named
John Locke,
John Locke.
John Law.
So like I found him and I emailed him.
Then he just wrote back like,
yeah,
just call me.
Here's my number.
And then I called him and then he,
we started talking about how you like,
what the events were like.
And he said the main thing about it is
the inclusivity.
He's like,
this is what makes it so cool is that we
like that if you really form a branch,
this is more of an experiment,
but if you really do it,
then everybody who decides to
participate,
they uh,
they come up with their own events,
you know.
So like everyone's like,
all right,
we're going to be doing this next
Tuesday if you want to come,
come,
if you don't,
don't come the following Tuesday we're
going to be doing this.
But there's no like pushing people out.
It's like if whoever wants to be
involved,
let them be involved.
And then everyone kind of gathers
together in this little weird bubble
that forms,
which is like,
dude,
when you're in pajamas at Gelson's
watching people,
it's what we were talking about earlier.
What is the sane way to live?
Right?
So when you're in Gelson's wearing
pajamas singing,
do you want to build a snowman?
And you look out and people are kind of
like walking with their shoulders down
to buy their evening groceries and
they're just kind of like,
look over at you.
They get the biggest smile on their
face.
They don't know what's fucking
happening.
We don't know what's happening.
But it feels so cool.
It's like a really like,
exciting moment of like really minor
rebellion that has no impact ultimately
in the flow of society.
But in that tiny moment it's like,
fuck,
we're in zero gravity here,
man.
Yeah,
I mean a coordinated effort like that
with a bunch of people in pajamas
singing.
Do you want to build a snowman out of
nowhere would make everybody smile.
Yeah.
It's one of those like,
what in the fuck are these guys doing?
And Dude,
you'd look over because it was right
next to the Deli.
So like people were like sitting at the
deli pretending to like be eating their
dinner.
But they kept looking over it like
Brendan giving the Tiger Woods speech.
But that's the other,
that,
that's the other cool idea that they
came up with man,
which was,
um,
it's like the way we do entertainment
right now,
it's so weird because it's like in and I
guess thank God for it because it's our
jobs,
but like people pay a cover and they go
in and there's the audience that sits in
the audience and the cut and the
comedian that talks or the entertainer
that talks and there's this weird
distance between the two and it's like,
so that relationship between entertainer
and entertained,
their ideas like what's merged together
so that we're entertaining each other
for no reason other than like let's just
fucking get together and like see what
happens,
you know.
Now this was a nonrisky thing.
Like a lot of their thing is like
elevate the risk,
elevate the risk to the more you elevate
the risk,
the more it's like a crucible kind of
that really brings people together,
which is I think,
the idea of taking people out to the
fucking desert.
Originally.
It's like let's just take a group of
these people launched flaming pianos
with catapults.
I want to bring up before I forget,
Brendan Walsh,
one of my favorite stunts that he did.
This is,
this gives you an indication and what
kind of sense of humor has he
put a fake wholefoods sign in Silver
Lake?
Yeah.
He wanted people to think that a whole
foods was coming to.
So,
I mean,
there might be one now,
but he did this a long time ago and
there was a lot.
It was an empty lot.
So he had a sign made with the whole
foods low put coming soon on it.
Yeah,
there it is.
And he set it up on the fence and people
were so psyched.
Yep.
That is Brendan Walsh,
man.
That's what his sense of humor is.
So cool.
And Dude,
he uh,
he,
um,
that's why when I read this book,
look at this right there.
They'll get the top of it.
Did the silver lake wholefoods hoke
prankster.
Reveal his plans on a podcast.
Oh,
he did it on a.
What the fuck with Mark Marin?
Thus when he,
uh,
he revealed it,
I guess.
Yeah.
He's so fucking funny.
Funny Man.
Such a trip.
He said,
dude,
he commits to this.
The other thing he does is he fully
commits to this and like I like,
I mean I'm not saying like he does a lot
of stuff and he doesn't care if people
know and that is to me another really
cool thing about.
He's a funny comic too.
Funny Dude.
He's all around funny dude.
Like fuck dude,
for that kind of Shit.
Just the way his mind works.
What did he do
recently?
He went,
he went up somewhere.
I want to say it's the Improv maybe.
And he had them introduce him as one of
his friends.
He went up and he did that guys act
jokes.
That's so fucking silly.
Commit to 100 percent man because like
when you're standing and fucking pajamas
and a Goddamn Coulson's reading tiger
woods,
10 minute speech and you don't back
down.
It's cool.
But anyway.
Yeah,
tails for the cacophony society.
You guys look into it man,
because it's pretty cool and anyone can
form a branch.
Anyone listening,
you can start your own branch.
You could just do it and it's really
fun.
Sounds like fun.
I don't know about the Ukrainian thing
though.
Well why might have copyright on that,
what might not be able to call something
you cry and that was our last meeting.
So it doesn't matter when you resolved
your differences with the Ukraine.
So we'll let it go.
It's over.
You know,
you were talking about burning man
before the podcast.
We were on the phone we were talking
about and I said,
dude,
we shouldn't even talk about it until we
talk about it on the podcast because you
were.
You were ranting about burning man is if
you had seen the messiah year bounding
utopia.
No,
it wasn't a near beating at all.
it was great.
Your look at that picture.
That's fucking cool.
Like that.
That the right behind that is a right
behind that is this incredible.
Just never ending field of art.
So by that those lights,
those lights are all led lights shining
on the fucking art that people are
spending all year building for.
No other reason than to fucking bring it
out there and give people like just
beautiful,
beautiful art.
Like that idea.
I had no idea.
It was so lit up.
Oh my
God.
I mean that you can't see.
The crazy thing about burning man is you
can't capture it in pictures.
Like you've just got to go there because
if you see the pictures,
it kind of seems ridiculous or dusty or
whatever.
But my God man should do a documentary.
Has Anybody done a documentary on
Berlin?
Yeah,
there's tons of people of color,
but we should do a documentary on it.
Dude,
how about this?
How about just like we should take
someone to burning man would never go
to.
I have an idea.
You just don't.
You just come.
That's all.
No documentary.
You just come and we'll spend a week
having fun there because dude,
you like.
Here's an example.
This is one of my favorite fucking
places there that it's called.
There's a.
So it's all free bars,
bars,
people put up free bars.
It's free booze.
Nothing.
No,
you can't buy anything there.
So one of the bars,
and I forgive me if I,
if I say the title wrong,
because now it's a little fuzzy in my
mind.
It was my favorite bar and always called
the something like the Ministry of
Disinformation,
but it's set up to look like an
information booth and so we're riding by
and these you're ride around bicycles.
My friends who have been there forever,
they're like,
dude,
go to that bar and they'll just lie to
you.
Like that's how they do the bartender
just lie to you.
That's alert.
So like you go there and you like,
so like you sit in there so good at
lying to the point where,
because everyone's knows that they lie,
so people come there to get lied to and
so like you go there to get lied to,
but they know everyone knows that
they're lying and they flow you in to
thinking they're done with the lying
part.
Right?
So like we're sitting there drinking
may,
being core sitting there drinking and
like,
you know,
the guys made some pretty obvious lies
and they weren't drinking.
It's like,
hey.
So we were really feels like,
oh yeah,
okay.
Now we're just talking like friends.
He's like,
say,
Hey,
do you guys want to try some of vodka
that like,
uh,
I home brew?
And were like,
yeah,
we'd love to try some.
And so like he pours it and we drink it,
and he were like,
wow,
this is actually really good man.
You should,
you could probably sell this stuff,
like where you're going to start selling
it.
And he's like,
yeah,
we're a,
we worked out a deal with South Korea.
You slap an American flag on anything
out there and they'll buy anything.
Like,
wait,
oh wait,
you're still lying to us like,
you didn't make this vodka.
You're just lying.
He's like,
no,
I'm serious.
Look,
look,
look.
Then he pulls his phone up and there's
pictures of it.
This is this still that I use to build
it and it's this ridiculous still.
They like definitely,
definitely isn't something for the Dukes
of hazard.
Then you realize like,
oh my fucking.
And then you're like,
you,
you're still lying.
Like you've haven't been telling the
truth.
And he's like,
listen man,
I'm not good at lying.
Like I just like my friends do this
thing,
like I come here,
I'm not good at lying.
I just tell the truth while I'm up here
and like other people will lie to you
here,
but I definitely don't do that.
So they go deep and they commit and
it's.
But it's not malicious.
It's really both.
It's a very funny thing and that's one
tiny little part of it.
Like imagine that spread out over and
over and over and over again with just
different types of like bars or art.
Imagine like let's say and you know,
I don't take psychedelics and if I talk
about it on the podcast,
I do it as a joke because I want to seem
cool,
but imagine if you were in the middle of
the fucking desert on psychedelics that
had just started kicking in on your
bicycle,
covered in led light,
surrounded by other people in blinking
led lights on their bicycles and you're
sitting in front of what appears to be a
massive bras.
What is either a locust of firefly,
some kind of grasshopper cricket's
sculpture on top of another crib,
get sculpture that has combustible gas
exploding out of it so that it's.
And it's like 10 feet,
15 feet high with combustible gas,
exploding out of it.
So it's making this.
Elon Musk has the dopest rod there.
He's got a yacht that like just goes
around through fucking burning man and
life goes on it,
right?
Yeah.
And anyone can get on.
That's the other thing about it,
man,
is it's like this is,
it's the idea of.
The thing is it's pure inclusivity.
That's the idea is it's like this is
just everybody sharing.
There you go.
So crazy ride through the desert.
You climb on,
they'll give you,
they'll give you drinks.
You just like chill out.
It's like the whole thing is like a
gifting economy is what they call it.
So like everyone is just giving stuff to
answer was amazing.
It's the best.
It really truly is.
Okay,
so here's,
here's the question,
can this go from here to a city?
Can,
can,
can you develop a city like.
Well,
they,
they do have,
so like I think the answer that is right
now probably not,
but why not because it's resource based
because it's,
it's more like,
okay,
imagine like a flower that once a year
blimps.
Right?
So that's what you could say.
That's maybe what burning man is like
during the year.
Lots of people are like getting together
and planning like what they're going to.
I'm,
I'm planning with my fucking burning man
camp,
the enchanted booty forest.
We're planning art,
uh,
art car for next year and that's going
to take all year to figure out what it's
going to be and how to do it and how to
put it together and how to get the money
told you spend too much time burning
man.
You're fucking brands become your life
now.
It's every year's just downtime,
downtime,
burning man.
Well,
I will say,
I mean,
I know it,
it truly is the most embarrassing there.
I know.
I sound like that guy in that brilliant
youtube video that someone made
parodying the ear beatings that burning
man.
People give their friends.
Have you seen that?
No.
Oh,
please pull this up.
No,
we can't play.
It will get.
Oh my God,
look up.
Look up.
Look up the youtube video.
So how is burning man?
And it's like this guy in fucking
goggles and burning man attire being
like,
how was burning man,
you can ask me how wasn't burning man is
a better question.
It's everything because you really do
like when you're there you're like,
oh my God.
Yeah,
that guy just like ranting to his
fucking girlfriend.
That's when you turned into he's got the
goggles on those dirt goggles,
which I guess you have to have.
Did you wear them?
Like you have to wear them because
they're these fucking dust storms kickup
and like.
But I'll tell you man,
crazy.
A,
you have to wear a dust goggles.
Here's the craziest thing about it that
with all that being said,
there's a place there called the temple
and it's all of these are like,
a lot of these are built by like genius
architects.
The temple.
I can remember how much it they said it
costs to build like I have been like
75,000
or 750,000.
I can't remember.
It's this incredible like you can pull
it up,
look up the temple,
burning man,
2016,
uh,
or you can look at all the different
versions there,
there,
there.
That's it.
So,
so everyone.
So everyone's like go to the temple and.
But it's really heavy when you go there.
So we didn't even know what they're
talking about.
So you pedal land and you see people
standing in front,
like people seem to be crying.
People are hugging each other.
Dude,
you go into that thing and it's filled
with pictures of people who have died
that year before.
Baby close pictures of dogs.
Pictures of like,
it's where people go to burn there to
grieve for people who died in their
lives.
Man.
And so you walk into that place and this
is in the middle of this incredible
festival.
You walk into that fucking place man.
And like you just,
you start,
you just start crying like people in
there because you can feel this like
just nexus of grief bubbling up and it's
the most intense create.
The only time I've ever felt that kind
of energy is in a place called Vara Nasi
in India where they like burn bodies
there.
It's that same kind of like sweet grief
of people morning.
But then that's the last thing they burn
at burning man and whoever's left when
they burn it,
which is probably like 60,000,
50,000
people,
they all sit around it completely
silently.
They sit around at silently.
You might hear someone playing a flute
and the distance or something,
but it's just imagine 50,000
people sitting around that thing on fire
quietly is emperors of all these
pictures of people who've died the year
before go fleur,
who whenever they've died go flying
through the air and then when it finally
burns to the ground,
the entire group of people,
they how like docs.
Yeah.
And that's the end of burning man.
Holy Shit.
So cool.
This is growing at a staggering rate
every year.
What's to stop these people from
claiming a city,
like if everybody just decided like,
Hey,
let's all move to Portland.
If all those
people that are burning man type folks
just decided to try to have the same
sort of impact on a community that's not
outside the realm of possibility.
Right.
Well,
it's already happening.
Is it happening?
What's happening?
Wherever there's people who have been
influenced by that festival,
he turned back into the world and try to
not be such selfish shit ads when
they're in the world or maybe try not to
waste so much stuff or like it's also
happening because you like realize like,
oh fuck.
This is not only a festival.
This is preparing for the fucking
possible economic collapse because if we
can all get together and survive in the
desert in this way and work together,
then there is a possibility.
You know?
Actually I went to see Alex and Allyson
Gray.
There are painting at the Dr Bronner's
camp.
They're painting a mural there.
Doctor Bronner's soap,
hemp soap.
Dr Bronner has a camp there called Risa.
Yeah.
Dr.
Bronner's soap.
They have a camp there called
reformations,
right.
And so they basically are just hosing
down all these filthy like burning man
people out in the desert to clean them
up.
Right.
So like after they hosed them down,
there's a,
they've constructed a tent where there's
a Dj playing music and it's dripping
water down and everyone's naked dancing
and Alex now allison gray or painting is
beautiful mural in that tent.
And so like we,
you know,
corn,
I went to visit them and we walked up
and like,
you know,
those guys are so fucking cool man.
But then Alex starts with talking to me
and he's like,
you know what?
This is right?
And I'm like,
what do you mean?
He's like Dr Bronner's family was in
Auschwitz where they had the showers and
so this is the opposite of the showers
at Auschwitz because it's like naked
people in real showers dancing the music
in this like fucking super loving
environment.
So their idea was to mirror the
holocaust or to create like,
not that you could do that,
but to create like some,
like a response to it.
There was like,
here's what it could look like instead
of gassing people.
There could be a DJ dripping.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
They spray it down.
But anyway,
man.
Yeah.
Like you know,
one of the things that Alex Gray was
saying is this is the seed of a global
civilization,
but seems to be.
It seems to be that would be.
There's something going on,
man.
There's a shift.
There's a consciousness shift.
I mean there's this far reaches on both
sides.
I mean there's people that are resisting
it hardcore.
There's a lot of hardcore trump fans
that are resisting,
you know,
illegal immigrants and they want a
hardcore republican values.
There's a lot of people that are still
clinging to that,
but then there's a lot of people that
were going to Bernie sanders re way too.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people that are
realizing why you watch these,
to duke it out like King Kong versus
Godzilla.
What's interesting is the real loser is
the system itself,
our confidence in the system.
Our confidence in the system is at an
all time low and people that are your
age and older people like me,
I'm 49.
What are you?
40 three now?
Forty to 42 now to consider it.
We're like middle aged folks,
whether we like it or not,
but we grew up with no internet and then
we were exposed to the internet and now
we're seeing things like wikileaks.
The kids of today,
they're going straight wiki links from
fucking high school.
Right?
They knew about that in high school.
They they watch all the videos in high
school.
Those are the ones that I get the most
upset about.
When someone posts a video about the
flat earth or any kind of fucking stupid
shit where you're going to waste a lot
of time paying attention to nonsense,
right?
Not The world's Goddamn round.
They have a lot of video of him.
You can go around it in a satellite.
You can go around in a jet.
It's not a fucking hoax.
Stop thinking about that.
It's a waste of time.
There's a lot of other shit to
concentrate on,
but you'll get lost in that you'll get
lost and then that upsets me that,
that pisses me off and I've been
responsible for it myself.
Sure.
On this podcast or said a lot of shifts
that turned out not to be true.
You know,
it's usually our obsessions are
temporary,
but I think what I like what you said,
that the system is kind of short change.
It gets out.
It reminds me of A.
I just watched on Netflix now it's
Luther's a crazy weekend I think as cod.
And you saw the one with Al Sharpton.
Yes.
And he's talking to Al Sharpton and he's
like,
I feel like I let you down by not
getting arrested and Al Sharpton's
response as you let yourself down by not
getting her as did and,
and,
and then at the end of.
I don't want to do a spoiler
boy,
the one man.
Now I'm thinking I didn't see that one.
I saw a bunch of bots binge watched on
the first time.
The fucking.
This episode is about black.
Are they black power people?
Blacks?
I don't know,
I don't think lives matter.
No,
it's like for that,
this is like nation of Islam.
This is Pete.
Like the one of the guys Louie was
hanging out with was like a hardcore,
like black.
He hated white people.
White people are the devil.
You're the devil.
Like,
uh,
but he was actually really sweet at the
same time.
You know,
he's like really smart too.
This is a guy,
I can't remember his name.
Dr Khalid.
Uh,
he,
he actually,
I looked him up because I always really
wanting to like follow him on twitter,
but he died of an aneurism but whoa.
And a crazy hardcore charismatic guy who
wants like the United States to give
back a swath of land to black people so
that they can go live there and like,
but you know,
Louis Theroux is such a likable guy that
you could see that they were both kind
of liking each other when they weren't,
you know what I mean?
And it was really sweet to watch and
really cool.
But you could also see that he was being
moved by recognizing how much a lot of
these people have gone through and how
fucked up it could be.
And this is before any of this shit
happened with the recent police
shootings,
is that another police shooting in 2001
and they were going to go march about
and Sharpton was going to get arrested.
But then so anyway,
like yeah,
like Sharpton was like you let yourself
down by not being part of this by not
getting residents like it.
It's true,
man.
While these people are up there fighting
like those fucking God damn cats,
the Cro lord into a fight,
while they're up there debating and
fighting and where our eyes are fixated
on that,
we can easily lose track of all this
stuff that we have definite control
over,
which is we don't need to.
We don't need to be so selfish.
You don't need to be so selfish.
And if you start experimenting with
giving stuff away because you guaranteed
man,
there is stuff that you have that you
don't need.
You literally don't need,
like in your garage that you covet kind
of like there's shit you covet that you
don't need,
you're not going to use or you have like
a hoarder mentality where you're like,
wow,
I might sell it one day,
who knows I'm going to definitely need
this vibrating bed one day or whatever
the fucking thing is that you have.
You don't need it.
So you could do an experiment where you
try to give it away.
Not to,
uh,
not to a charity or foundation,
but you figure out someone in your
community who maybe needs that thing for
real,
like someone who could actually use it.
It doesn't have to be some lofty thing
either.
Maybe you got like an old fucking xbox
and your garage and your friend doesn't
have an xbox.
Give your friend the x box just for fun.
You could do these little experiments
and when you do it,
wow.
It feels good.
It like is a really great feeling to
start offloading shit.
You don't need into the community of
friends and family and people around you
are a fucking.
Some people really need stuff man.
And like,
it won't hurt you at all.
And so that,
that to me is like when you talk about,
well,
can we,
could burning man turn into a
civilization?
I don't know,
probably not like,
you know who?
Um,
well I won't say who it is,
but one of my friends was out there and
he works out there and I'm like not high
on psychedelics,
but I'm looking around and I know he's
been going there for a long time and I'm
like,
could this become society?
And he's like,
no.
He's like,
if these people are out here for more
than four weeks,
they start killing children.
Whether that ready for that yet we're
ready for a couple of weeks at a time,
a couple weeks at a time.
But 1:52
in a year.
Yeah.
And in the meantime you can actually
just kind of start experimenting with
not being selfish.
How about instead of looking at it as a
negative,
just experiment with being generous.
Ah,
there you go.
Think of generosity is the ability to
drop little love bombs.
Yeah,
that's,
that's how I've always tried to
approach.
I've seen.
Do it man,
those aren't little fucking love bombs
you leave.
I've seen not to like I've seen some
fucking weeping waitresses when I turned
back to look as you're walking away,
Matt,
and like that thing that you're doing
there,
um,
that thing that you're doing,
that's it.
Like that thing everyone can do that.
You don't have to be the host of the UFC
to be able to you,
you.
So like,
God forgive me.
I tried to
explain this to someone who was saying
that it was a stupid thing to do.
I was like,
you,
you have to think of,
you know,
they were saying that like they're going
to expect it.
Every time a rich person goes there,
they're gonna expect larger tips and
it's really not proportionate to the
service that they've given you about.
You can make someone happy.
It makes them unhappy and you don't feel
the difference.
The difference between you leaving a one
number on a check for a tip and they go,
oh,
that was a good tip or another one
another go holy shit.
Like now they feel really good.
Like they just got a gift.
Like that's what the tip thing is,
the tip things.
That's it means that it's one of the
rare things that we have in our culture
where you could express gratitude in a
numerical amount.
I mean,
I'm not saying that's the only way to
express gratitude because of course
there's a way to express it with your
words and your,
you know,
your love and all that good stuff,
but you can express gratitude in a tip
form where you,
you,
there's a number you can attach to it.
Yeah,
like somewhat.
If you have a.
If the bill is 50 bucks and you leave 50
bucks,
people go holy Shit.
And to a lot of people the difference
between $100 in your bank and $50 in the
bank,
it's not really,
you're probably not going to feel that.
For some people you will be well,
but you know,
I was just,
you can do it.
I went to visit my dad in Florida and my
girlfriend and I,
we went to this arcade that gives out
tickets.
Like what are those arcades that
dispenses tickets.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like you play fucking skeeball or
whatever you'd like.
It's like a little.
It's like a casino for babies,
right?
So it prints these fucking tickets out.
You take the 10 tickets to the counter
and you get like a piece of shit thing
that you'll never use like a nasty,
like bear made of like Chinese and as
bestest or something,
you know.
So like they exchange is dumb.
Anyway,
so these tickets we ended up accruing
this massive pile of fucking tickets.
Right?
And so we're standing there looking at
this junk and then I looked down and I'm
sure other people out there have done
this.
There was like a kid who's got a tiny
little bit of tickets and he's like
looking at like the candy that a little
bit of tickets and I'm like,
Hey kid,
take this.
Gave him this huge fucking stack of
tickets.
Dude.
The look on that kid's face and him and
his brother
that,
you know,
that look is way more valuable than any
kind of piece of shit behind the
counter.
Right?
That is the essence of it,
man.
It's like the,
the,
when you drop these love bombs off,
this is not a one sided thing.
You're walking away feeling really good
because you know what you just did.
You impacted a person's weak.
This,
this person might not have money to get
their kids fucking groceries that week,
man.
Now they do.
They might not have been able to make
rent.
Now they can.
You're walking away.
Having created that shift in a person's
universe as temporary is,
it may be.
It's still a shift in the direction of
the positive.
Right?
So what you've done there as far as I'm
concerned,
as a kind of magical act kind of miracle
and any anyone can do this man like you,
you,
like do,
they're like people who would go around
with like spray bottles and just spray
your sunglasses off for you,
which out in the desert is really
important because all the sand gets
caught in there and you can't fucking
see that's what they had to give,
you know,
it was just like helping you in that
way,
but just that was still fucking cool
man.
So just there giving a service to people
and they don't expect anything out of
it.
That's it.
They're just doing it for love.
You can do.
Anyone can do that.
There is definitely something you can do
that you're not doing and you're not
doing it.
Not because yourself is.
You're not doing it just because you
haven't even realized you can do it.
It's like having a superpower that
you're not aware of,
which is like,
fuck.
Just give something away.
Like it does.
You don't need that shit.
Whatever it is,
just get the fucking thing away.
Super Hippie Duncan Trust.
Oh yeah,
you're the anti-trump.
When are you going to run for President
Duncan?
When are you going to run?
Well,
why don't you.
Why don't you do ask a question or
answer a question with a question that's
rude.
That's a poor taste.
I.
Well,
I'll tell you man.
My hope is that glue without you and I
will run.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Move.
We've got to get out of here before it
blows up.
Out of here anyway.
Who is going to blow up?
Is going to be fun to this thing,
this America you think it'll.
Cause I don't know if this is going to
work,
dude.
I'm looking at this election.
I'm like,
this thing's just,
it's too volatile.
Good.
Let it fucking collapsed by.
If it fucking collapses about children,
people are going to be.
What about the infrastructure?
You know,
I just had this conversation with.
I had this conversation with Chris Ryan
and my podcast.
We got to do a shrimp rates united.
And he said that,
uh,
he was talking about how post,
you know,
after disasters,
everybody gives to each other and people
are very kind.
So if there was some kind of economic
collapse,
some calamity or something,
then I think what people would suddenly
realize is like what would happen is
that pendulum that swings in front of
the eyes of the sum total of all people
in this country and convinces us of the
importance of this small group of
secretive people.
Maybe for a second,
that thing stopped swinging and we like
look away from it and look at each
other.
And we realized like,
Oh shit,
we've got each other.
We're going to be okay.
The fantasy of the fucking road.
People like grab your guns,
go rob the rich people,
all that stuff.
The idea that it's going to be some kind
of like the La riots times a million
years.
I was like,
oh no,
that's not what it's like at all.
It's like we can help each other
together.
I get help you.
You can help me.
We didn't need them as much as we
thought we did.
We maybe we didn't need them at all.
We've got the fucking roads.
There's people who know how to fix
roads.
I know how to do stuff.
You know how to do such a super hip and
we need the fucking system.
Goddammit.
We need trucks to bring in vegetables.
We need to sewage system that works.
We need power.
We need to direct the programs.
Programs.
I need to watch my programs,
my fucking money to refrigerator.
That works.
God dammit.
I need data.
You need westworld.
I need a hospital that's clean.
Yeah,
you do need that,
but guess what?
It could still happen.
It can really happen.
I think such a hippie it.
There's no hospitals and that burning
man,
just cleaners.
They do have like a full hospital at
burning man.
No,
I didn't go visit it,
but they say they have like a,
like a urgent care medical facility
there.
That's really nice.
And they fucking need it to [inaudible]
like you think I'm a fucking super
hippie man.
Do you think they have like a checkbox?
Like do you have an injury or are you
freaking out?
Man?
Well that's the,
that's the Zendo project it,
maps is doing.
So one of the cool things that Doblin is
doing is they have a thing called Zendo,
which is this,
it's called psychedelic harm reduction.
And so they create,
like in the Porta Johns at burning man
there,
these signs that they put up that say a
night,
a little night,
a little weirder than you expected,
like come here.
And so like you go to this place and
it's like,
dude,
you gotTa have this guy on your podcast.
His name's,
uh,
Dr Cole Marta.
He's a psychiatrist.
He's like one of the people involved in
the MTMA for ptsd.
Um,
uh,
experiments that they're doing,
they're in the phase three clinical
trials.
Maps is but so he volunteers at the
Zendo.
But basically what happens is it's the
safe space that Doblin is created where
you go there if you're freaking out and
you're like,
am I going to get fucking arrested?
And they're like,
no man,
just sit down and relax and like these
are trained,
this Guy Coal Marta man,
like there's smart train clinicians and
if they're not clinicians,
they've peaked.
There are people who have been through
this program who just sit with you and
let you freak out without judging you
and like just sit with you and let you
relax until you're having an okay time
again.
And then they let you go back.
So instead of like losing your shit and
like getting arrested or losing your
shit and being around your friends who
were like,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
Man?
You get to be around like really smart
trained people who know how to,
how to like not just like help you
relax,
but help you use this event to like
transform your life.
Because a lot of times a bad trip is
like a transformative moment for someone
if they're around the right people.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
maps is incredible.
I know,
man.
I've done so much cool shit and Rick
Doblin,
just such an interesting guy.
I've had him on twice had a chance to
talk to them on the podcast twice.
He's such a fascinating dude.
He's a warrior man.
When you look at the how might he spent
his entire life like we know we sit here
and we fucking rail against the system
and marijuana and like ahh,
but Doblin man,
he's like on the front lines,
like this guy is like deeply,
deeply involved in doing it the right
way.
He's doing it through the system.
Yeah,
it's cool.
It is cool.
It's interesting like he was detailing
like getting it passed and what was
going to be entailed and getting this
therapy through and then what would be
next and how this is a longterm thing
they're doing over long,
many,
many years.
Oh God.
He gave.
He gave a talk at burning man.
That was just like when you like he just
detailing the like the war on drugs and
like why it's happened and what it is
and then like his step by step plan and
then you realize like this guy is in a
phase three,
phase three of clinical trials which
never happens.
Like with a schedule one substance that
theoretically could like the results
that they're getting are very good,
but if people who have ptsd,
if they go to the doctor,
the doctor will be like,
well I'll prescribe xanax and maybe
they'll give you like cognitive behavior
therapy or something,
but like the idea that there might be a
way to give someone Mgma,
mgma mixed in with like a specific type
of therapy and that that could actually,
I don't want to say cure,
but they set their mind to lift the
this,
the weight of,
of this horror off of them or at least
allow it to like dabble and explained
why he thinks that works.
I'm not going to try to repeat it,
but the idea that this could work for
real is just the most incredible thing.
Man.
That guy would.
He should get a Nobel prize.
I think he did explain it on this
podcast,
Sydney to.
Do you remember Jamie?
I don't remember either.
I feel like you did though.
I feel like he explained how it works.
It's like you're when you.
Apparently it's something to do with
short term longterm memory,
so when you have a traumatic event,
it gets stuck in short term memory.
Somehow it's looping there.
It's not getting filed away in the right
way.
God forgives me.
Everyone listening.
Doblin coal,
Marty,
whoever.
I'm ruining this in front of,
but like it like it apparently something
about revisiting the experience under
the influence of Mtma causes it to
somehow be refiled in the right part of
your brain again,
so it's not sticking out in the
forefront of your experiences,
so it's not like it.
The thing isn't always there like a
flash bulb light or something.
Another thing that's infuriating.
I mean that's almost
to me is infuriating.
As teenagers getting hooked on flat
earth videos,
it's more infuriating even that this is
always been there.
This has always been there.
This has always been there and they made
it illegal and all these people that
suffered could have,
could have gotten relief through this
all long time ago.
A long time ago.
I now,
man,
if they just recognized this early on,
had been super objective about it.
Look,
look,
clue.
We clearly have an issue with ptsd in
soldiers and police men and people that
have gone through domestic abuse.
There's a lot of people with PTSD.
They can.
This king literally changed the course
of our nation,
but do you keep up the fucking.
Dea is corrupt system to keep up this
nasty business of arresting people for
the wrong kind of drugs while they're
selling drugs.
Everywhere you look to keep up that
system.
They literally stopped something that
would have helped everyone.
Buddy.
Man,
can I just.
I don't work for maps.
I've never used.
I do a plug for them real quick.
Yeah,
so guys,
if you actually want to chip in to
something super fucking cool,
go to the maps website.
Right now they are raising money because
Doblin has got a manufacturer.
I can't remember.
Something like five kilograms of MDM,
a for the phase three trial so you can,
you can go to maps and actually chip in
to to to have it well,
to get ecstasy,
to get Mtma,
to vet people with ptsd and it's a
really cool thing if you want to chip in
money for it.
Super fucking cool.
Like that's like how often do you get a
chance to buy Mtma for people with PTSD?
It's amazing.
It's really fucking cool man.
Because they have these incredible.
They have a supply of old MTMA and I
think it's like they can't use it
anymore.
They've already raised $148,000,
but they need.
They needed $400,000
for five kilograms of Mtma.
Well let's see what we can do.
See if we can get some donations going.
Maps.
This is my kind of telethon.
Come on guys.
Come on.
It's going to be putting people on
public radio.
I was listening to this Mckenna
interview once and he was on public
radio,
is a recording of him on public radio
and it was so annoying and so like if
you enjoy this program,
please donate.
They have that weird way at talking
where it's just as gross as a strip club
Dj.
You know what I mean?
It's like there's a way of talking when
you're talking about public radio.
If you enjoy this show,
you enjoy these programs,
please donate.
We require your donations.
It's the only way we stay afloat.
If you appreciate this show,
if you appreciate fresh air with Terry
Gross,
that will be coming out later.
It's the Portlandia affectation.
Well,
it's.
It's now it's national public radio
speak.
It's.
I am a super sensitive guy.
I am a liberal.
I'm absolutely left.
I lean left.
That was what that guy in Canada,
he used to talk bad about.
The guy who was accused of beating the
fuck out of these girls that he was
having sex with.
Remember that guy,
John Ghomeshi,
they kicked him off the radio show
because all these women were claiming
that they had sex with them and even to
like beat them up and shit.
Oh yes,
yes.
He would talk like this.
Hello.
Welcome to the show.
To take a leak.
I'm sorry.
Please go.
Urinate.
Judge may have to go urinate judgment.
There's no judgment.
Everything's cool.
No judgment,
no judgment here.
In a few moments we're going to ask once
again that you call the number on the
screen or donate.
It's very important.
Donate.
We require your donations to stay afloat
here.
If you enjoy the state of ferns today,
which is our new piece that we're
working on.
Love happiness and wholefoods.
Stunk and trusts on Brendan Walsh.
They have a piece they're putting
together for us.
Don't get to become a super hippie.
Have you noticed something's different
burning man?
Yeah.
They got got out of the hospital.
They have there.
Was that from 2014,
but they have a cool looking 300
employees at a hospital that has 52
beds.
Wow.
It set an actual hospital,
Humboldt,
general hospital employees come and help
people.
They have tickets for burning man to
write.
I think if the biome now.
Doesn't that sound crazy?
That seems like it doesn't make any
sense,
but this is the only way to keep people
from overwhelming place because you're,
you're gonna if you have tickets,
that means you can only sell a certain
amount of tickets.
It means Bernie man sells out.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
like this,
uh,
the service here,
the,
the hospital was paid for by the burning
man organization.
It costs $455,000
for that year.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
That's.
Oh,
so that's where the tickets go.
that makes sense.
To show their website where it all goes.
Well,
it doesn't make sense though,
is limiting the number.
Does that?
Doesn't that seem illogical?
Well,
yeah.
I mean if a 150,000
people in that hospital now is fucked,
they can't,
but they just have to ramp it up based
on how many people buy tickets.
As long as you just keep having tickets,
then you'll have more money to spend on
more hospitals and you would just sort
of plan it accordingly,
but maybe they're trying to like slowly
develop it where they don't want it to
get completely chaotic and out of
control,
which is what it definitely would do if
they had no restrictions whatsoever.
Duck.
And while you were urinating,
we were talking about the restrictions
on the population at burning man and
then I found that to be a little bit
odd.
It makes sense that they're selling
tickets to it because especially there
were.
We found out how much it costs for the
hospital.
Four hundred and $25,000
for a year or something.
Is that what it was?
Fifty five.
Four 55.
So.
But why wouldn't they just allow more
people to buy tickets?
Why wouldn't they just keep selling to a
number I might guess would be that.
So it's like they have to work out deals
with growth and like the surrounding
areas and what's lock.
Go relax the town right before you get
to fucking burning man.
That once a year just gets like this and
this huge
influx of Dell,
but like they are.
Yeah,
there it is.
The bureau of land management,
Bureau of land management is the same
thing that manages a public land for
like hiking and fishing and rafting and
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
And so like basically if you look at
that,
you could see that because they have
given in this and basically it's a shake
down.
Right?
So like if you want to do this festival
Europe paying us well,
would you say that it's a shakedown or
they want to control the population
because they didn't want to getting out
of control?
Oh No,
I know of land management has a
reasonable being dev a reasonable
concern that it could get completely
overrun with hippies and it would be
massive.
So there's a,
there's definitely a reasonable concern
and there's also like,
uh,
there's also some,
maybe I'm not,
I don't know.
Perhaps there could be maybe some
profiteering happening,
but here's my question.
Why wouldn't they make more money by
allowing more people in if they really
want to tear the move is to just say,
I don't think burning man material.
No,
I'm not saying burning man.
You Sound Bureau of land management.
Yeah.
Why would they just open it up?
Eighty $1,000,000.
Oh my God.
I that burning man's expenses.
Oh,
30.
Yeah.
Thirty million.
One hundred $85,000.
Burning man was once a scrappy little
desert gatherings become a multifaceted
professional operation.
Today.
The burning man project produces the
nation's largest permanent event on
public land and supports and extensive
global network of events,
artists and civic initiatives.
Man.
He.
Well,
I can't believe that's so much money.
Do you want to hear something?
Even dod million.
One hundred 85.
What's.
What's crazy about it is when you look
down,
there's no trash on the ground.
That's what's really not too bad at it.
They call it the matter out of place.
Boop,
boop.
So like what they do after the festival,
they will like go from camp to camp,
looking for where the trash is and if
they find any trash they like,
like if someone's,
let's say broken in a bottle or
something,
right?
They will bring like a team of 11 people
in to sift through the sand to get every
single bit of glass out of the fucking
sand so that it goes back to being just
what it was before alkaline desert.
And that's,
that comes from the cacophonous because
one of the good confidence sayings is
leave no trace.
So they,
the idea is like they go to a place,
do they're insane thing and then leave
and it's like they were never there
before,
which is pretty trippy to take us so
bad.
It's so bad ass.
It's amazing.
So cool.
Yeah.
I wonder like this didn't exist 30,
40 years ago.
Like what's it going to be like 30,
40 years from now?
I don't know.
It's hard to say when people give up the
ideas that have sort of imprisoned each
generation about keeping up with the
Joneses
and about belonging to the right country
club and about all the things that
people strive for.
Moving up the corporate ladder,
you know,
all that stuff and clinking glasses like
you're in a fucking Leonardo dicaprio
movie before it takes a turn for the
worst traits.
I mean,
that's,
that's literally what it is before it
all starts getting crazy.
You're clinking glasses.
That's what everybody's hoping for.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're evolving,
everybody's evolving and we're learning
a lot of stuff right now and like what,
like,
you know,
we're learning a lot of stuff and part
of I think hopefully what we're learning
is that certain things cannot be
commodified,
that there's no way to really put a
price on certain things.
And you know,
a lot of people there,
it's not like they're against money or
against people making money or anything
like that.
The idea is like make money,
spend the whole year making money,
but then let's fucking ignite it in the
form of your amazing sculpture that you
brought out into the desert.
The other cool thing is too,
when you're looking at these sculptures,
you don't see like a plaque that's like,
this was made by Tim French.
Follow me at Tim.
You know what I mean?
No one's,
no one's signing their fucking work.
So like you're out there and it's like
you're standing underneath some out
chemical like sphere,
nickel,
laser,
globe.
That spinning in a way that the lights
make it look like the ground you're
standing on is like rotating and
shifting.
Who made that?
Why did they make that?
How did they get it out in the desert?
How are they fueling this?
What the fuck is this?
Or like the Mat.
There's tesla coils everywhere out
there.
Like just tesla coils sparking in the
fucking middle of the desert.
Someone got a tesla coil out to burn it.
Like just when you consider getting a
tesla coil into the middle of the
fucking desert and then setting it up.
So it works.
I think they have videos.
I would.
If you look at it,
it's pretty cool looking man.
That just sitting out there.
That's amazing.
Just one.
Just one thing.
Or like Dick Slides.
What does that giant thing,
that guy next to the tesla coil.
I don't know.
I didn't see that.
Who knows?
Floating eyes and what's in his hands.
I don't know.
Didn't see it.
They have Dick Slides.
They have like these slides shape like
Dick's that you can ride through like
your sperm getting shot into a pussy
fucking trippy festival.
It's the coolest thing ever,
man.
They have an entire spectrum of just
insanity out there.
That thing.
Wow.
Fuck.
Look at that.
It's pretty amazing.
Or that.
Look up the catacombs.
Look up the categories.
These guys made these like crazy
pyramids out there.
The catacombs.
20 16 burning man.
You should look up like the burning.
Oh,
you're not allowed to show it.
Well you could show up and you know
what?
So these guys made like,
look at
that.
Whoa.
What is that?
They made these fucking pyramids out
there,
man.
That's a drawing like.
Yeah,
there it is.
Like with wood,
Yeah,
and they do this during the time that
they're there and then they burn it.
They,
they come in early so they come in like
a cow like three weeks earlier.
I'm not sure the exact amount of time
they construct this thing and then they
just fucking burn it.
They burn those things in the morning at
like 6:00
AM dude.
Yeah.
You could see.
Look at the dust devils that kicked up
next to it.
Like whoa.
A dust devils are incredible.
That's wild man.
A little dust.
Tornadoes and just roam through the
camps.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
When these storms kick up,
it's the most beautiful,
insane thing.
It's just all of a sudden out of the
blue,
everything goes from being completely
clear to just being completely obscured
with this very fine dust,
which is why everyone's got led lights
on because the lights glow through the
dust so that you don't run into
somebody.
Whoa.
Oh
yeah.
What a weird choice though.
Why wouldn't they choose to do it
somewhere where it's like nice.
Well,
I think that statement they're making is
we can do this in the middle of fucking
death.
Think what we could see you everywhere
else.
You think they did that on purpose?
No,
I think it evolved like the.
I think that originally the idea was the
cacophonous had this idea of what's
called the zone trip,
which is that if you take a group of
people and bring them out of their
natural habitat and you then something
kind of magical happens and so there's a
story of how will.
The first time they went out there,
they drew a line in the sand and they
are like everything after this line as
the zone and like that's when that was
the first burning man is.
It just was like they just picked a
desolate place so they wouldn't get
bothered by people because what was
happening is.
I can't remember that.
I think it's Larry.
Will you look up Larry burning man.
Larry.
I can't remember his last name.
Really?
What?
Larry Harvey.
So what was happening is Larry Harvey
was going to the beach.
He went to the beach and they just burnt
this like an effigy of a man.
Right.
They just ignited this effigy at the
beach and Larry Harvey won't say why
they did it.
It's really cool.
They won't.
Everybody wants to know like,
well what was their reason behind it?
So like they just went and burned this
avid g out there and then they were
doing it like I think a few years in a
row and it kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and then the somehow
the cacophony society got involved
because it got so big one year the cops
wouldn't let him burn it and so then
they were like,
they ended up scheduling a cacophonous
event,
which is what I've got the flyer,
my phone.
It's like the burning of the man and the
black rock desert.
And so they like redid that event and
took the burning man out there.
That was the first burning man.
And then they started doing it every
year just like they were doing it at the
beach in San Francisco.
But it kept getting bigger and bigger
and bigger.
And then it became like a.
it's like,
oh,
it's like a confidence to vent basically
that spun out of control and now it's
turned into this.
I think.
What is one of the largest festivals on
earth?
Look,
when is it?
When does it take place?
Labor Day weekend with the.
I'm not sure.
Like the first week in September last
week in August summer,
so it just ended the summer,
so it just ended a few weeks ago.
Well,
I think you can look it up.
I'm not sure that data.
That can be totally off on that.
I don't know.
Either way.
It doesn't matter.
I'm sounds crazy.
It sounds amazing.
Yeah.
It's pretty incredible,
man.
It's pretty cool.
You got to go,
man.
Go next year.
I feel like maybe I do have to go,
but when you go,
you got to do it,
right man,
because the problem is like a lot of
people,
they're like,
I mean you could do it whatever way you
want,
but there's like,
are you telling people how to do it?
I'm going to tell you how to do it.
I'll tell you how to not do it.
How do you not do it?
Well,
you heard what happened to the camp,
the wide ocean camp out there,
right?
What's the wide ocean camp?
So there these camps called like,
you know what the White Ocean camp is?
I think that's that story.
I don't want wanna blow story Buchloh it
when you want to see people's power
lines and shit because it's like the
problem is like there's like you could
be a little too inclusive there and so
you end up like part of what's cool
about that thing is like a.
The thing I saw in an interview with
Larry Harvey,
he's like,
this is a survival situation,
right?
So it's tough.
It's not easy all the way through.
Like you,
you got to get out there in a fucking
rv.
We drove an rv out there,
man.
Now that's hard or anything,
but it's like when you're driving an Rv,
I'm out of burning man.
It's not easy because it's a eight hour
line.
Get out of burning man in the morning
and your rv.
You're sitting in a fucking rv for eight
hours and this massive line of people
who are being pulsed out of burning man
because there's only one road out,
so this is every time you want to leave
through any day of burning man to leave
early.
You won't have to wait that long.
But if you go through the whole festival
it takes that long to get out.
And so the point is it's not easy.
It's not.
It's not necessarily supposed to be
easy.
Like it's like part of it's really
fucking hard and like really tries you
for real.
Like it's like you're going to get it.
It's true.
It's not easy.
So some people think that like there are
people who are kind of subverting the
experience a little bit by like flying
in on a private jet and then being
brought to a place that's already been
built for them where they get to kind of
hang out and then that place is like
theoretically it's not so easy for
people to get in there.
Even though wide ocean,
like one of them at one of the things
they said was like,
well,
we're giving food to people,
but it's,
there's an embarrassing embarrassing
post.
One of the guys from wide ocean put up
like what you did do us,
and it was like a guy who clearly didn't
get the whole point of the thing,
which is like,
seriously though,
why would they do that?
Instead of just complaining or just
talking to them like why would they cut
their power?
Why would they make
their food spoil?
That doesn't seem like a logical choice,
right?
Dude,
there's some good.
Is that a logical choice for me?
No.
Hell No.
Of course not,
but they think it makes sense to them
that they cut the power and they
sabotage these people's food.
I think that that's what they did,
right?
Well,
yeah.
They fucked up their camp.
They apparently glued there doors shut
and stuff,
but that seems contrary to the idea
behind the event itself.
Well,
that's the crowdsource.
No one idea at that event.
You're hearing my perspective.
My perspective is one thing,
but that ain't the only fucking
perspective.
Dude.
There's like a bunch of people out there
who aren't there for a laugh.
There's like people who are like,
I mean God.
Have you seen the gladiator ring they
have there or they slam people to who
fight or the fucking fisting tent or the
fisting tent.
Like fisting in the genital fisting.
He,
yeah,
they have a tent for that.
They have an orgy tent.
Fistula tent for fisting.
Yeah,
there a fisting tent.
I didn't go to it,
but I heard about it.
How would you not go to it if it was
there?
I don't know man.
If you build it,
they will come visit one of those things
where the only way in is someone's got a
fistula because that would stop me.
But.
Or You could fit them.
Would you be in a fist in somebody you
know,
I just to see what's like,
I think I can imagine what it's like.
I don't,
I don't know.
That particular thing isn't like,
it doesn't appeal to me.
But uh,
I do like the openness of it and I do
like the fact that like eventually after
a bunch of people walking around naked
for a week,
you stopped seeing naked people and one
of the people in my camp,
it could be a lie,
they say they have something called
acceptable boner Tuesday where Pete guys
will take fucking cialis and just walk
around with fucking bonkers.
It's crazy,
dude.
I got my own ideas of it.
But like,
there isn't one idea about it,
man.
It's not like a tame.
There you go.
Orgy Dome rules.
One couples and Morrison's.
Morrison's only.
Yeah.
Why is that?
It's more sums.
Okay.
To take off your shoes.
One couples and Morrison's only meaning
that you can't come in there by
yourself.
Who is your gym here to fuck?
You got to bring someone that fuck you.
Take off your shoes.
Use Blue towels under.
You asked before you touch,
clean up and throw everything away.
Clothes and zip.
Both doors.
Hilarious.
The orgy dome rules.
That's uh,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
But it's not shocking.
All those people took a photo of the
orgy dome.
Yeah,
they're all,
they're like,
hey,
we fucked.
Knowing that.
It's like not a big deal.
It really though,
isn't that big a deal if you think about
it,
like we're not like we make it a big
deal.
It's not that big a deal.
It's a big deal because we decided it's
a big deal,
but it's something that everybody does.
Like sex is what either everybody does.
Everybody wants to do.
Almost nobody except the rare few that
are actually asexual.
Yeah.
It's something that everybody does and
yet we make it out to be this horrible
thing.
Yeah,
and that's a very like if you're into
sex,
definitely that's a great festival for
you because.
Perfect.
Yeah,
there's a lot of like,
stuff like that that goes on and
everyone's super like.
I mean,
I don't know that the fucking gladiator
dome.
So what does that mean?
That I was at all metal or wood?
That's metal I think so you can like
climb up there and watch as they like
slam these people together.
So it's like a mad max fighting.
Will they take these people,
put them in these harnesses and these
ropes getting kicked?
Yeah.
Is he getting kicked?
Yeah,
he's getting kicked.
So the the swing and they beat the shit
out of each other in there.
Wow.
This has been Nana's.
Is there video of this shit or just
videos?
Go right to that police.
The battle.
The thunder dome.
This is real.
Yeah man.
Oh my God.
What in the.
They're hitting each other or hitting
each other with sticks.
Sticks,
sticks.
But you could definitely kick pI.
mean,
it definitely doesn't feel good.
Wow.
This is nuts man.
Yeah,
this is really strange.
Hear his people screaming and yelling.
Yeah.
What a fucking trip.
And they police in this at all.
There's cops everywhere.
Cops everywhere in burning man.
There's cops.
Oh my God.
Who would the cops what?
There's cops walking around with cop
outfits on.
There's costs with the cop outfits and
undercover cops with the cop outfits.
What do they do?
They just wait for someone to shoot
somebody beat somebody up or something
like.
So I got to tell you man,
I was.
I most of the cops I saw,
they seem to be having really funny
conversations with people at burning
man.
We were just talking to them like some
of them are,
you know,
there are arrests,
but like from what I saw there,
it's not like the after.
I think for a cop after being at burning
man for three days,
I think their perspective starts
changing maybe a little bit because
they're in this weirdness just like
everybody else.
I don't know,
maybe that's naive to say there's
undercover cops there and people from my
camp said one of the things that people
do is they'll go to where there's like a
party or a rave and yeah,
there you go.
OPS on Atvs.
Yeah,
there you go with the Times.
Yeah.
It's pretty funny.
They're just like doing that.
But like one of the,
one of the things they do is they go,
they'll go to like with monopoly money
with like fake money and fake plastic
bags and do fake drug deals so that
suddenly the undercover cops will come
out and then they can.
Then they will follow the undercover
cops,
you know,
because it draws them out.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
They do fake drug deals.
That's what I heard with fake money.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if it's true or not and
let's end on that.
All right,
cool.
You've changed my perspective of burning
man here,
man.
I'm glad we talked about on the podcast
because I'm glad we stopped the
conversation on the phone because you
were so adamant about.
I'm like,
we got to talk about this.
I'm glad we did,
man.
Okay,
now I'm super compelled.
Alright,
see you next year.
The end.
Cool.
Awesome.
That was great.
That was so fun.